hello everybody hello hello we are back with more batman no no no no no no no no batman all right give me a sec i just forgot to uh adjust me audio for batman it's uh i was right like i said i was right down um what the audio is so uh um you know so i don't have to be like sound guy What is my audio?
Is it balance sound guy?
Oh, by the way, remember that fun fact I gave you guys last Batman stream?
I found the article.
I found...
For those who weren't at the beginning of my stream, I gave everyone a very fun fact about our beloved Adam West.
Adam West, when he used to do the Batman show.
And oh my God, let me read you this article that I found.
That was where I got my fun fact from.
Batman legend, Adam Wentz, once had sex with eight women in one night.
It was the swing 60s with free love.
The late Adam West, who played Batman from 98?
I was like, how do you even, at that point, like, how do you even pay attention?
not enough hands for that like he is we i'm just like how the fuck does that even work at that point yeah that's just impressive from the late adam musk who played a batman from 1966 to 1968 sometimes used his superpowers for bad the sun compiled quotes from bert ward who played sidekick robin that detailed their lash of this pre-tabloid era exploits.
Britt and I were like kids in the candy store.
It was a swing 60s with free love.
And women threw themselves at us.
Jesus Christ.
I had young female co-stars in my dress room at 745.
That's too early, bro.
745 in the morning.
Holy shit.
Sadly, the rubber suit presented its challenge because of the physical limitations of the costumes.
Bro, I was just like, oh my God.
His long-term time sidekick, Bert Ward, now 71, has backed up West's powers.
When I entered Batman as a naive 20-year-old who had only dated a couple of girls, I met Adam West would immediately introduce me to the wildest sexual debauchery that you can imagine we often found that women were banging on our windows like while we were bedded down with other women we start we're talking about wild times in the dressing rooms on the set between the shots in the lunch wagon and then of course doing the personal appearances on the got wild the suit stays on batman and to be honest with you we became like sexual vampires bro the 60s were fucking wild bro like okay look at this this is what robin said look at what okay this quote is actually crazy warren confirmed the costumes had so to do with it if you look at our costumes if you look at our show you'll see that we always stood with our legs open our fist on hips and our bat bulges forward which had a profound effect on women now you guys some of you guys who have never seen the batman show from from the adam west era
Let me show you what he meant when he was like, yeah, back then, like our costumes, they had a profound effect on women.
So you must be wondering, wow, these costumes must have been so fucking good.
They must have been like, holy, the sexiest things I've ever seen.
These were the costumes, by the way.
These, these, These were the costumes that made these women swoon to the point where Adam had eight women at the same day.
Like, God, that's so sexy.
Good times.
Are you not attracted, dragons?
That would make any women crazy.
Women and men crazy.
chick magnets right there the vintage wrist oh yeah it's the first day of knowing that November 2 oh I'm sorry guys if this is what's gonna make you lose I'm sorry guys
so yeah um so I found yeah so if you guys want to uh you guys want to read the article to be fair I basically read the entire article to you guys I had to know Because I know some of you guys were like, we're fact checked.
And I was like, here's the fact.
Here's my sources in MLA format.
Here you go.
Dango, thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
Adam West is simply the truest American hero.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Source provided.
That's like crazy.
I was like, I would not expect that, you know, seeing this.
Seeing this and...
Guys, they were sexual vampires, guys.
Batman!
I'm such a dad.
I think it's just the costumes.
I think the costumes were just...
Did not appeal.
Like, was not very good with, like, making someone look good at it.
Like, it was just impossible to look good in that costume.
Because, like, look at this.
between like Adam West in the costume and then Adam West in like I guess like half half naked I think I think like I think like the sexiest person alive can't make this work can like it's like he's like a different person I'm surprised the suit couldn't even like show any of the muscles at all it looks like he gained 30 pounds from just wearing the outfit um no i because i also have this tweet on hand too because i was like okay i gotta show this on stream too i gotta i gotta i gotta make sure you guys see this tweet as well which is where i got my fun fact from um originally yeah suit suit is definitely a debuff i think the suit is a But apparently in the 60s that I just,
I guess I didn't have taste in the 60s then.
I guess women were throwing themselves just from the costume alone, which is surprising because I'm just like, I'm just like, what, what, how bad could like other costumes be if this is what the women were throwing themselves into?
Or it could be the drugs.
That's true.
season.
Um, if you cannot from the suit, then you don't deserve Bruce Wayne.
All right.
Anyway, that's my fun fact of the day.
Uh, all right.
Anyway, today we're gonna play Batman.
Um, also I've learned from just people because I was like, what the fuck does, you know, Wayne Industries do?
Apparently they're just a pharmaceutical company.
Well, like their main business is being a pharmaceutical company because that's what like his dad did and obviously bruce inherited the company so like so like me putting people in the hospital is just making me richer so the rich is actually the rich their rich keeps getting richer like i'm at literally big pharma so me trying to not so i understand that why he doesn't want to kill because these criminals are literally his source of money so yeah i'm literally doing it and criminals I beat up the more I'm I'm making from Wayne Industries yeah it's like that's why the hospitals are always full it's all it's all about the bottom line he says it's trauma but I believe it's for like he can't be a millionaire if he oh my god 12% I you can tell that I've not been doing any of the bonus stuff he says it's because of trauma but We know the real reason,
guys.
We know.
He needs more, he needs more clients for Big Pharma.
Okay, line launcher.
Boop.
Wee.
I don't even remember how I remember how I died.
They had like, they had, they like stocked up on security somehow.
All right.
Oh my god, it's the fucking, it's the same Riddleway trophy I got last time.
I really didn't say the Riddleway trophy.
Yeah, each criminal and it's my own paycheck.
What the fuck?
Oh.
Okay, it was RT.
I don't know why I thought it was B.
You see the way penguins guys just ran.
Alright, we gotta deal with these guys.
I'll kill him first.
Okay, I don't think he sees me.
Yeah, he doesn't have the heat sensor, so we're fine.
Oh, shit, never mind.
Oh, shit!
Hey, wake up, man.
Come on, wake up.
Yeah, oh, shit.
Give me a sec.
I know what to do.
Watch this.
Snow.
Still!
That's fine.
I do this and then I fly up.
And then I go this way.
They won't know.
I knocked him out.
He has a short-term memory now.
He lost his short-term memory.
Watch this.
Still!
This way!
He went this way!
Okay.
Look at that.
I'm okay.
See?
He doesn't know.
Watch this.
Steal!
Drop kill it!
There you go.
Steal!
Oh shit.
I did it.
true stealth experience look at that and that's how you do it and that's how you stealth thank you in the super chat thank you thank you don't keep hearing my theory of batman sending people to hospital from the last batman stream yeah it's literally if that's why he's a billionaire i swear because i'm like bro there's like making like weapons are very is very expensive thing is like creating new gear also he built a fucking uh he built a fucking space station with his own money for the justice league like how is he getting them i know yes he's big pharma but even big pharma doesn't make that much money like he helped fund the fucking space station um the space station headquarters for the justice league yes they do But they do.
Yes, okay.
Like, if it was just a space station.
But he has a fucking bat cave.
Come on.
And then he has to play child support for seven fucking kids.
There's, okay, or maybe six.
All right, there's Damien.
There's Dick.
There's Jason.
There's Barbara.
And then there's, like, there's like another female Robin recently.
I don't remember who she was, but I remember there was another female Robin somewhere in the comic universe, in the comic user universe, and then there's Tim.
Yeah, so there's like seven.
He has to pay child support for seven Robins.
Like, so it's like, not, like, where is he getting that money from?
He has to keep sending criminals to the hospital to keep funding his enterprise.
How do I get out of here?
oh my god it was actually a who the fuck is stephanie brown just like there's another female robin i just know about one of them there might be like yeah but you know batman batman's the one that's funding barbas like you think you think when she does her whole um oh my god what is her secret identity not the back girl one the one after she got like a shot in the back um Oracle.
You really think Gordon is funding her Oracle side job.
You really think that, guys.
She goes to, she has a, she's a college student.
You really think she can afford all that fucking tech?
You know, Batman is, you know, Bruce Wayne is secretly funding it, her little side hobby.
Oh yeah, with that boy, policeman salary?
You really think a policeman's salary can do all that for her
All right, I'm so lost Yeah, Bruce Wayne is the sugar daddy.
Hey guys No, not shields shield can't protect them from above where Joker get these things from anyway.
I don't know.
I'm like, how do I do aerial attacks?
of tiger shields i mean those guys are pretty tough right jay's got some feel with strange yeah there's no thing i can do area attack for him need to know basis okay how come no one told me maybe you just don't need to know oh wait there is give me a sec guys it's good thing they don't know i'm here because i'm the master of stuff i do this and then how do i reach that
hello I see it what the fuck oh I had to do in combat okay oh oh wait that's so cool that's right slam dunk not if I kill you first that's right oh my god wait this new I'm gonna forget how to use this It's so cool, but you know I'm going to forget how to use this move.
Welcome to the jam.
I'm going to forget it.
That's too many buttons.
Three buttons is way too many.
One or two, that's how I work it.
Anyway, let me tag this real quick.
Okay.
Where am I supposed to go?
Oh wait, this is the main area.
It's this way.
Yeah, three is just a little too much.
Is it here?
Oh my god, sorry, my ex sent me another voicemail.
God, he's so obsessed with me.
But I told him, I told him, if he gave me super aids, it was over.
I told him to get tested.
You have one missed call.
That's it?
Are you serious?
I'm not sure that you got my call.
Oh, my God, it really is.
It really is like an X trying to reach you right now.
You have one missed call.
Oh, my God.
Bro, how many missed calls?
How many times has he tried?
Holy shit, he's so clingy.
You have one missed call.
bro I know you're not dead I'm missing a girl Oh my god Guess that means you know About the guns already That's so relevant
God bro he needs Another one
Oh my god I feel like he's like Drug calling me
It's still going Bro he sent me Not even in an hour He sent me eight He called me like Eight times in 20 minutes Oh,
he finally ended.
He finally ended.
Bro, he's...
Oh, my.
Bro, he's so clingy, man.
I don't answer his call one time, and my phone has, like, has, like, 20 messages.
He missed what he...
It's his fault, guys.
He regretted it.
He didn't know how good he had it until it was gone.
Don't leave, bro.
Bro, he fucking poisoned the...
He poisoned, like, hospitals with his blood.
What the fuck do you mean?
Don't leave him on red.
Alright.
Oh, guys, that was a bad idea.
Bad idea.
Bad.
Guys, what I thought.
I didn't...
Look, I didn't realize there was an army.
How the fuck was I supposed to know that?
Okay.
Jesus Christ, there's so many.
Bro, this guy's been like, oh yeah, watch that!
Okay, I might have crashed the party.
Okay.
There's just too many.
I can't do combos right now.
There's way too many going on.
You don't understand.
There you go.
Oh my god, there's so many people here.
Oh my god.
This guy fucked over my combo.
Bam!
Yo.
My nuclear fist!
Fat Man don't kill!
But Fat Man will send you to life support.
Because you gotta pay those medical bills to keep yourself alive.
Your family's gotta keep you alive.
And life support is very expensive.
That's how I make...
Money and Wayne Enterprises.
24-7 care, that's right.
24-7 paycheck.
The real killer are those pills.
A fate worse than death.
Get out of here.
Nice.
Wait, RTA?
Oh, it's this.
Wee!
Alright, that was easy.
Where do I go?
I wish I have a map.
Alright.
Hack time.
I'm in.
A compartment.
I guess this was- Oh, it opened back the subway entrance.
Citizens of Arkham.
Facility.
A new inmate.
More nostalgic among you will- Oh, wait, he's the mayor?
Why did we nominate him?
How the fuck did he become mayor?
No, it doesn't.
I don't get it.
We'll be sent there.
Yeah.
Scrub that.
How the hell did Strange even manage to have the mayor arrested?
I don't know, Barbara.
Brides.
But I am going to find out.
That's what bribes are for.
Okay, interrogate Quincy Sharp for information on Hugo Strange.
Are any of these side missions fun?
Like, are any of them actually, like, fun lore-wise?
Or are they, like, annoying?
Yeah?
Alright, which one's a fun one?
All of them?
Choose one.
I'll do one side.
I'll go to one side quest instead of saving the city.
Like, one of my robins can take care of the saving part.
That's what having seven children that I've adopted is for.
That's crazy why I don't have a robin helping.
me right now like what's the point of adopting seven kids which one AR no that does not sound fun the AR the body near the green this one the plain one
they do not need a sleep our entire job is to do things at night what the fuck why did why did nightwing name himself nightwing if he's not gonna fucking do save crime at night
well change his name to gay wing.
Which one do we do?
Do we do the doctors one?
The SOS?
The distress?
We're not doing AI training.
I heard AI training sucks.
Or the...
An identified murder victim.
He's in another city.
Who gives him the right to move?
If I can't move, he can't move.
I bet there's not even that much crime and blood even doctor or body near okay I will do this one we'll do that one he's a grown ass man living off of my inheritance you think he had he's living off of my money that I earned from beating up criminals there's no way bloodhaven is worse than Gotham City.
Or maybe, I mean, it could be, because there's no actual billionaire to, like, you know, um, have, at least they have, like, at least Gotham has good health care.
That's the only they could think of.
Wait, how could Bloodhaven be Jersey when Gotham is Jersey?
What is it?
Is it like, is Gotham old Jersey and then Bloodhaven is New Jersey?
Gotham is New York City.
Oh, Gotham is New York City.
Wait, that's the key.
Wait, then who's the billionaire in New York City?
What's this say?
What is this?
Tim.
There's the body.
I can't leave the mayor to die.
I need to go back.
Oh.
Wait, whose body is this?
How is he murdered?
Sad is deceased.
Is that not how I'm supposed to...
That's him.
I'm trying to scan it.
How do I scan it?
Oh, I have to do the mirror first?
Oh, he's not letting me do the side quest.
Ah, Batman's like, I don't care.
You're not important enough.
Guess I'll cancel it then.
Batman's just like, you're not that important to me.
He only investigates dead people whose net worth is at least a million dollars.
That's true.
Yeah, you're right.
He's not paying any hospital bills.
He's a ugly son of a bitch coming back here and telling me You got beaten up by someone else.
I've got a reputation to hold in here.
I can't just let them all think I've got some whiny little bitch working for me, can I?
Whoa!
Why?
It's because I'm about to hurt you so bad.
Oh, it's over here.
If any of those other jumps come up to you, you'll stab them in the face rather than...
Hey.
It's Batman!
There you go.
I'm a hero!
I was like, you'll do what?
Oh, I did it.
I rescued someone.
Alright, nice.
Hey, guys.
What are you guys talking about?
I thought he was going to kill me.
Yeah, you're right.
You thought he was going to kill me?
You thought he was going to kill you?
No, no, no.
You can't kill.
I need you in the hospital.
If he kills you, we lose another potential patient.
Alright.
Let's see.
Is it worth it to just upgrade armor instead of all the other stuff?
I feel like I don't use any of these other things.
I don't use my gadgets that much for fighting.
Loitering is a crime.
That's right.
I don't know.
Disruptor update.
Oh, it will?
Which one is that?
Is it this one?
this one.
Oh, Firearm Jammer.
There you go.
Normally, without the enemy being aware that the guns are carrying, once disabled, these targets are shown as blue, and Detectable, so you can be easily undentified.
I'm also used to disable... Oh, okay.
I'll try that.
LT.
Heart RT.
I'll get the destructor.
Alright, get there.
It's here, right?
It's above me.
I remember you from the asylum.
You personally ordered a six-week course of electroshock therapy to cure my more violent here oh is it here oh it's here well guess what it didn't work wait i can use my new thing where's my disruptor
i dragged your sorry ass to my new boss he'll make me his right hand man for sure all right watch this
Self!
And that's how you stealth.
Wait, how did he unjam himself?
The whole thing was to jam it.
Oh.
There you go.
It's jammed.
So you can't do anything.
There you go.
And then...
Oh, wait, he got back up.
That's illegal.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here!
Boom!
Alright.
It jams until he reloads it.
Alright, oh, there's the mirror.
I'll color blue.
Five foot eight.
Quincy Sharp was a warden of Arkham Asylum on the night that the Joker broke free.
Unknown to both, but discovered by Batman, Sharps suffered from a split personality assortment, accompanying atrocities in Asylum, believing himself to be possessed by a spirit.
In reality, he was being influenced by Hugo Strange, who had provided Sharps with powerful mind-controlled drugs that allowed him to manipulate Sharps' behavior, enable him to plant the seeds that led to oh, so he doesn't have a split personality.
Strange was just like on, his brain is not okay after that.
Like, I'm pretty sure he lost like 50% of his cognitive ability.
How did he get even nominated?
Like he, I will say like during Arkham, I feel like the warden of like Arkham, he was not a good warden in Arkham Asylum.
What were the amount of criminals that never, because the whole point of the asylum is that it is used to rehabilitate the criminals?
Because that's why Batman puts him made the asylum, put him in the asylum, because he thinks like he could fix them.
But like, they go to the asylum and they're never fixed.
And I would say he is a terrible warden.
I would
say, I will say, knowing that he has not succeeded in rehabilitating any of the criminals in the asylum, why the fuck would I nominate him as mayor of Crime City?
Like, It was worth a shot.
Okay, interrogation time.
Oh,
that's not good with the blood in his brain.
His already very much dead brain.
I'll tell you everything.
Strange came to me back at the asylum.
He told me he had friends, powerful friends, the sort of people who could make things happen.
All I had to do was turn a blind eye to a his experiments and work on my campaign he said his friends would ensure that i won who are they oh that's how he won oh it was actually corruption i was like how the who the voted for him i'm pretty sure like voter turnout is also very low in gotham city because then it requires the people to go outside it made perfect sense the scum of gotham needed
has been removing anyone with evidence again it's always corruption enjoy your legacy
that's how he got in the power okay he really would vote for this guy okay we put joker in the asylum last week and now he's out again i just had a chat with my old friend quincy sharp he confirmed that strange is working with someone else i'm going to find out who what are you You need to get that blood to freeze now.
I will.
I just need to.
No, you don't.
You need
me.
Oh, there it is.
Who's that guy?
Hello?
Hey.
Who are you?
Hey there.
Wait, who's this guy, Moon?
Is he the Moon Knight NPC?
I have been watching you, Batman.
Me?
To see if you are ready.
Oh, fuck.
What the fuck?
Ready for what?
Who is this mysterious?
Who is the mysterious figure?
Save vigilant for the sightings and scan the clues he leaves behind.
He's like the Catholic Moon Knight.
He looks like Moon Knight.
Unknown, unknown, unknown.
He's like Moon Knight if red.
Do I do?
How do I... Does he leave any more clues?
Hey Batman, can you hear me?
It's Officer Jones back at the museum.
Oh, it's a map-based puzzle.
Oh.
Guess I will never complete it.
Alright, now we can do this one.
It's very appropriate that he's like the DC version of Moon Knight.
this way all right time to scan all right how did you die i should scan the crime scene to determine the cause of death how did you die fixation has been removed and the head wrapped in bandages what there have been three murders in gotham over the last month with the same mo the press have nicknamed the killer the identity thief if he's now in arkham city i need to track him down and stop Oh wow,
I bet for criminals, this is like prime real estate Because like I would say I'd rather like I don't know I'd rather like be in a city with Batman than be in a city with Superman Because the Superman can just like you like think about the crime and it's over for you Like because he has like super speed like super speed fly and strength Batman at least he takes time to get to you It's likely to have trace elements of the blood on them without realizing i'll filter the scanner to track the victim's blood particles that should lead me to the last person to see the victim alive maybe even the killer himself all right follow the blood trails where is it oh there it is i'm following
wait where's the rest of the blood oh there it is
following the trail it's nice that he he left a lot of blood If he didn't die from getting his face ripped up, I think he would have died from, like, blood loss.
Oh, hello.
Who's this guy?
Why did you kill him?
It wasn't me.
I'm not a killer.
I'm a plumber, for God's sake.
You've got to believe me.
I don't have to believe anything.
Tell me what you saw.
There was this guy.
He dropped the body there.
He was weird looking.
You won't believe me, but, well, he looked like Bruce Wayne.
What?
Oh, it's...
Someone must have got to him.
He was covered in cuts and bruises.
name.
Oh, it's this guy.
I know this criminal.
He used to be a rich boy, too.
He got, like, super jealous of Bruce Wayne.
Is it... It's Hush, right?
Yeah.
I know this criminal.
I know that guy.
I should look out for them.
Yeah, Thomas Elliot.
Yeah, he got, like, super jealous of Bruce and went, like, super crazy.
Of course I know his, though.
I told you, I'm a DC guy.
Wait, what did he tell me to do?
Wayne knew what he was doing.
Oh, fuck.
The phone's ringing.
Where's the phone?
Alright, there's... Yeah, it's hush.
Yeah, they're like childhood friends and stuff.
Find my phone now, Batman.
Or I'll carve this man's existence into my flesh.
Am I timed?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, where is the... Oh, my God!
It's so far!
As the fuck am I okay, it's fine This sucks This phone is so far I think he might as well just be dead It's literally on the other side
Alright I'm just gonna say he might as well just Just carve it now You know I gotta start zipping And gliding Okay all right how the fuck do i get there efficiently
how did i betray you i'm fucking trying to take a phone call you're not the only criminal in the city god he's so god he's so clean this is actual doom doom gowie he's so clean you guys he's so possessive you're right
okay this is much slower this is actually too slow
Oh my god, I made it.
It's on the other side.
We made it.
With one minute despair.
Oh!
You made it.
Oh my god, how many rich criminals are there?
I took to gambling.
God, there's no joke.
Where I am today.
Oh my god, he's literally Stewie 2K.
I think he just needs someone to talk to.
Like, I don't think he needs crying.
He just, he actually just needs a therapist.
Why we did it.
Oh my god, now we go back.
I forgot, like...
Okay, what is this?
Stop the random act of violence against...
Oh, wait, is this the...
Is this the Hush one?
Wait, what is this?
I lost the trail for Hush Because, oh my god, I don't even know how to do the hush one.
Because, because he fucking randomly called me.
No, no, I meant like, um, I meant like I lost the quest line for it.
Because, uh, Zaz called me and everything.
Oh, I need to find, oh, I finished it?
Oh, okay.
I just got, oh, you need to find another body.
I don't remember fully.
about Thomas Elliot's story but like I remember his like origin like the the whole like fucking cutting faces off and stuff and how he like tried so hard to look like how they were he and Bruce were like childhood friends and he's like his whole thing is that he he like he doesn't really have any superpowers he's just like a murderer um and like his face is covered in bandages and stuff because he got like plastic surgery
He's just weird, but I feel like, I feel like, uh...
That's just majority of the criminals.
They're just weird.
Yeah, he's like a- yeah, he's a- Oh yeah, yeah, now remember, he's a surgeon.
And he does, like, surgeries on himself.
Uh...
Oh, we gotta go this way.
Man, it's cold in here.
Tell me about it.
There's someone here?
Oh, okay, I thought there was someone in this random ship.
Woo-wee-wee-wee.
Oh, I forgot.
Probably froze up his old lady.
But did she look good to you?
In this place, they all look good.
What's stopping it?
I don't know.
It keeps freezing back up.
Yay!
Okay, we gotta go back.
in here how are we gonna get in we're not only you saw me what you heard Quinn's on her way over she sounded real pissed I don't think Joker's holding up too well she's coming over to try to hurry us up and when she asks what's stopping Joker getting his cure I'm pointing at you but it's not my fault you can tell her that you're kidding right do I look like I'm kidding no way I'm taking the fall for you not being able to defrost an ice cube okay look just staller i'll get this thing over absolutely super chat thing thank you is i spend too much money super chatting vtubers then you have super chat thank you thank you all right self oh wait i'm supposed to give me a sec let me let me feed up your friend real quick oh my god i wanted to do like the slam dunk on this guy god damn it what the he okay Fuck this.
Fuck this.
Alright.
Jesus Christ.
I counted!
My fingers were just too fast, guys.
My fingers were just so fast.
Okay, I got an idea.
Is there,
like, a guy?
Imagine that could...
What if I...
It's the bath.
Wherever you've gone, Batman, I'll find you.
Where is it coming from?
Wait, I can literally...
Wait a minute.
Battery!
You scared to fight us?
I have the high ground.
That's okay, right?
I've got the high ground now, boys!
It's not hiding!
It's called strategy!
And then...
Glide kick!
Boom!
There we go.
I'm right here.
Oh my god.
He fucking distracted.
What the fuck?
There you go.
I don't know.
My wife's not working right now.
I'm trying to do the counter.
Okay, there you go.
Got it.
That's right.
I got aim assist.
My fist got the aim assist, bro.
Bro?
Wait, wait, wait, I know what to do.
Wait, how do I...
Oh, there we go.
Boom!
I remember now.
Stun!
There we go.
Jesus, come on, let me punch him!
Non-lethal bomb!
Okay, we got...
Oh god, okay.
I think I got that guy out of it.
That's right.
Get the beat down!
Alright.
Nice, I got this done.
Oh my god.
Sometimes, for some reason, the Y isn't working.
I might need a new controller.
I'm using the Xbox controller right now.
Wait, what?
There we go.
Unfortunately, the...
The Batman game doesn't...
Uh...
Wait, it's not...
No, counter is why?
Why do you keep doing this to me?
Is this.
Oh, I can't counter the armor guys?
Oh!
I can't.
The Batman game doesn't allow me to use...
Doesn't recognize PlayStation for some reason.
If I could, I would.
I love it when Doki goes full shooter, oops, all projectile in the game before remembering to go back to the intended game mechanics.
Jakato, thank you, super chat, thank you, thank you.
Are there people here?
Oh, there are.
Oh, wait, I can hack this.
What's over here?
Oh, you snake.
How dare you talk?
behind my back do you know who I am fucking snake oh my god talking behind my back I fucking freed you I might have like threatened you but like it was just a joke I wasn't actually gonna kill you I might have taken your life try to take your life support but we all know it was just me being a little silly I
know where your life your warrior wife lives don't mess with me freeze your dead wife too impressive batman don't make me cut the power supply to gotham city your dead wife nora can't live without power i mean well she's not alive but you know her body's gonna start rotting the
formula is complete the bonding process appears to have been successful how are you feeling you look on well okay i'm afraid i cannot do that why you've given me your last order this is not a time for negotiation i think it is the clown has my wife bring her back to me
don't want to do this well i'm not like full power what if you give me the cure i'll be like in better condition to bring your wife back if he kills me he won't even get norah in the anyway you are in my world oracle freeze is attacking me get me the telemetry feed from his suit now no problem bruce remember what happened last time don't try to take him on in a straight-up fight Oh my god,
what the...
Oh my god, no wonder.
No wonder they, like, gave me so much area to move around in.
Oh my god, I don't know.
What does he want me to do?
Yes, I can.
Watch me.
Hee.
Like, what am I supposed to do?
Am I supposed to use the floor grates and be like, peekaboo
wait what how does he know
oh I have to sneak attack him there's no way oh he knows there's no way he knows guys how did he know and
he froze them
oh you can see he that's fucked up
I'll figure this out.
I'm trying to figure out how to freeze it.
That's cheating.
No way he knows I'm here.
There's no way.
Wait, what?
No, you don't.
That's silly.
Okay.
Whenever I do this, and I go all the way around him, you think he'll know?
And then I'm like, sneaky, sneaky.
Sneaky, sneaky.
That's right, got you, bitch!
Damage, don't look behind.
Behind them!
That's right!
Boom!
Oh shit.
What if I do that again?
Yeah?
Oh shit.
Oh shit!
I need to keep changing my tactics.
Oh my god, wait, that's not fair.
Wait, what do you mean I have to keep changing my tactics?
But it worked.
What do you mean?
I don't know what that means.
I can't believe it.
You mean I can't cheese?
That's right.
Wait, what?
I can't allow Freeze to see me.
I'm stuck.
Bro!
Get out!
Oh!
That's...
I all got him!
I was literally inside him!
That's not fair.
He fucking cheated!
He actually cheated!
That's fucking a bullshit!
That's right, get out of here!
That's fucking rock, got you now, bitch!
Fucking cheating ass!
Bro, that guy literally cheated!
I don't know.
Oh!
Whoopsie.
What are...
Tactics can I do?
Try to figure out what else I could do.
Fuck you!
That's right!
Fuck you and your wife!
Where is he?
Your movements are all too easy to track.
I
know someone was like, do it takedown.
And I was like, how?
Oh my God, he took, he fucking hit, destroyed all the vents.
Fuck you and your wife.
Trap down!
That's right.
Take that.
Boom!
Bye.
That's right.
Got your wife again.
Yeah.
I feel like... Wait.
Whoops.
That's not what I want to do.
I'm trying to figure out what other takedowns I can do.
Because there's clearly two more takedowns.
I could have got a takedown right here.
I'm so sad.
If the thing didn't...
If I didn't fucking go, like, right inside the freeze.
Or magnetize him.
This?
What do I...
How do I magnetize him?
There's another explosive wall?
Oh, there it is.
It's right here.
Try for how to get there.
Okay.
There's another wall here.
Okay, right here.
I just need him to go right here.
He'll walk over here, right?
Surely he'll walk over here, right?
Oh, I deactivated his gun?
Oh my god, you're a genius.
Okay.
Oh, wait, what?
Oh, shit, nice.
He's too busy fixing.
tech support that's right who is he doing tech support
all right i see you are attempting to use your weapons against me allow that nerd
wait that's right
What?
Oh.
That's fucking right!
Damn, should not have wore suit filled with metal, bitch!
Your lucky Magneto is X-Men!
Stop beating yourself, nerd!
Stop hitting yourself!
You're so lucky that Magneto's Marvel?
Please, find Nora.
She's all I have left.
You're so stupid.
If I was at 100%, it'd be easier for me to find Nora.
It's over.
What?
That was a lucky manufacturer.
Harley Quinn took it.
What are you waiting for?
Go and get it back.
The clown must pay for what he has done to us.
It's not that simple.
got the steel mill locked down getting in and someone decided not to give me the career while I'm fucking dying so now my brain is not okay I promise you Victor I will freeze blast high power it's up zero temperature project that will which detonates on impact used to solidify water oh wait the freeze blast New gadget.
Nora fries.
Or Nora freeze.
Beautiful Nora found undying love when she married the shy but brilliant cryogenesis Victor freeze.
Freeze Nora stays suspended until you get fired at care.
Since then, Nora has been trapped between life and death.
Yeah, you don't want me to fucking cut the power off of Gotham City.
Then she'll not have life support.
anymore.
Oh, I leveled up.
Okay, the firearm jam was actually pretty good.
Now I go back to...
Oh, heat signature conceal.
Okay, I like that.
That should be good.
Yeah, he's German.
That's why it's freeze fries.
That's why I are no J there.
Oh, new area?
What's this?
i managed
to track dora down to somewhere in this area the joker is holding free's wife and rescue here okay but this is joker all right i guess i guess i'll find your wife even though you threatened me oh he's he's austrian right i thought um let's see what is that all right i guess i'll unfreeze your work oh it's not here wait what what do i leave
you freeze my exit you fucking idiot
bro oh my god to use the other door oh
i don't know why i thought i had to fucking freeze the main area my in my head i i thought it worked
in my head it seems so logical i don't know why
i thought it would freeze both at the same time
this is not the exit oh it's up here we consider playing a demo for the button maze it just released yesterday what is that really thank you the super chat thank you thank you oh my god our mystery caller was correct it looks like batman himself is exiting the building
gonna watch that right oh that's it oh okay rescue vicky what about the pilot did we not just saw the pilot land in the walk guys what just like um what about the pilot that we literally just saw land in the water all right let's go save the way first and then we'll come back
Don't worry, we'll come back for you.
Gotham?
I don't know if you can hear me.
My newscopter has been shot down.
We crashed down somewhere in Arkham City.
We need help.
I am now stuck on part of the old Gotham freeway.
In what looks like a turf war between...
What the hell was that?
Oh god, there are snipers.
She'll be okay, right, guys?
I can see what looks like inmates moving in on us.
I need to save Vicky Vale.
She'll die if I leave her.
It's okay, it's not timed.
This is Vicky Vale.
I repeat, this is Vicky Vale.
If you can hear this, help me.
She's fine.
Oh.
It's a movie to die.
That's, I'll be here to protect Gotham.
Guys, I think Vicky I'll die.
All right.
You love Vicky Vale.
How is she that important?
She's just a journalist.
Wow, Doki, in a dying media.
I'm surprised that Clark Kent still has a job at the newspaper company.
Don't worry, I'm slowly flying over.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I'm here.
I'm joking
really is Owlman.
I honestly relate more to Owlman than Batman.
In the universe where Superman killed Joker.
At least Superman got the job done, you know?
There you go.
We did it.
It appears that the sniper is covering my position from the southeast have gone.
The roof of the curse is...
Yeah, yeah, somehow, for some reason, they're gone.
Or someone has taken them out.
Okay, stuff to take out down is not as cool as just beating them with my raw fist.
Alright, there you go.
If anyone can hear this broadcast, send help, please.
I'm here.
I can hear you.
You should be safe here for now.
stay here and keep out of sight any chance I could get an exclusive she's straight I saved your life no sorry I need a feed oh is that the Mad Hatter yeah I was gonna say it's the Mad Hatter who are you talking to no see what you've done I actually I knew Mad Hatter from Teen Titans this one wasn't from the comics I mean she's just like my knowledge of Mad Hatter that you caused.
At
least I answered your call, man.
The spotted man would have saved the helicopter.
That she should have worked in New York City!
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It appears I'm safe.
For now.
Yeah, who saved you?
That's fucking right.
Like certain death at the hands of snipers, all working for the Joker.
Yeah, Matt Hatter wasn't Teen Titans.
rifles in a maximum security prison that got them is a question i intend to put to professor strange if i ever get out of here i think that's weird shocked at the conditions on the ground live in gotham city facility you can literally go to a walmart and get a sniper here running wild murder and that's how big gotham city is right now complete lack of authority we were told that arkham city is good for gotham if that's true good comes at a price we shouldn't have to pay
the city.
Yeah, that sounds like the best plan.
Wait, what?
Good news, Master Bruce.
All right.
Oh, he did it.
Alfred did it.
See, when he is alive, he actually gets things done.
Spoiler alert, they killed Alfred again.
I mean, not again, but he's been dead for a while in the actual DC universe, which is crazy because it's like, it's, I don't know.
I don't know.
Maybe he got, again but like um because they always bring people back oh is he back again oh sorry spoiler alert he came back again they keep killing him off i can't keep track i can't keep track with because they also killed off batman for one second too for a bit they also killed off batman as well like for a while and then they're like damian had to like take over as batman and everything and then and then he came back he's like they're like jk he's alive Yeah,
no one ever actually did.
Like, go for the...
I should go for the cure.
I should go for my cure first.
He died, but then he got better.
Yeah, they had a whole fucking funeral and everything.
They dedicated entire issue to the fact that he was dead.
Like, a whole series about him being dead.
And then they're like, JK, he's alive.
I don't remember if it was because he faked his death or, like...
I don't remember the exact...
happens all the time so like i don't remember if he faked this death or like they like it was like jason where they resurrected him because it's hard to keep track at that point
silent oh that's fine there's way too many people here i'm just gonna leave
there's too many people i just leave
oh it's batman's just imagining him oh he's just oh batman's just being crazy as usual skitsa as usual.
Yeah, Uncle Ben stayed dead because he was only there for one issue.
Like, literally the first comic.
So it makes sense that they kept him dead, but, like, Alfred's been there forever.
JK, he didn't die.
He got sent back in time for some reason.
Comic logic.
Wait, how come they put him on hot ground now?
That's fucked up.
One of the guys saw him.
Oh my god, now they're all just in high ground?
Get your ass out of here.
Let's get these guys out of here.
Only I get high ground.
Alright.
Holy Batman has that privilege.
Who's he saying that to?
I'm not, though.
Oh.
All right, give me a sec.
I reached the objective for it.
I did?
Where is it?
Apparently I reached the objective.
I might be thinking about Teen Titans Go.
Because I have watched Teen Titans Go.
I know he has appeared in the Teen Titans.
Or the comics.
Because I did read...
I did...
Oh, I guess I'll help you.
Because the cure is...
right there you're so lucky the cure is here i did i did also read the they did do the comic series based off of the original t titans i'm gonna find some place safe to hide i knew mad hatter appeared in one of them oh did i watch the drop oh my god are you fucking kidding me okay i gotta get the cure first
Oh, is it this?
Oh, it is.
Batman the Animist.
I actually never watched the Batman Animist series.
I only watched the one episode
where...
What?
What happened?
Oh, it's the Mad Hatter!
I watched the episode about the...
What's her name, the little girl?
I can never grow up.
What's going on?
What a question.
Shall I tell him?
Oh, he looks so confused.
Maybe I should.
Well, it's so cool.
I planted a teeny tiny little idea.
Baby doll, yeah.
That's the episode I watched.
That was a good episode.
I'm sure you wouldn't understand, but as you can see, it worked.
You're mine now.
You're mine, and there's nothing that Strange can do about it.
Oh, are you not going to drink your tea?
It's special tea.
My special tea.
Go to hell, Jervis.
Simply put, I made you see what you wanted most.
Oh, it was all hallucination.
Alfred didn't find the cure.
Oh, tell me.
So predictable, just like Alice.
Never doing what I want without ludicrous amounts of psychoactive control.
That's fucked up, bro.
Well, if that's what's necessary, it's a good job that you've already taken them.
All we need now is a finish.
Does she want to take psychological drugs?
Ah!
You are my soldier now, Batman.
You will do everything I say.
That's the one where the Baby Dumb episode.
I didn't really watch the...
What the fuck?
What's going on?
No, no, no, no.
This isn't right.
You can't be doing this.
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
Oh, I'm going crazy.
It belongs to me now.
Oh, don't tell Joker.
He's gonna be very mad.
Shh, don't tell Joker.
He's very jealous.
He gets very, very jealous.
You're running out of time.
Wait, I'm timed?
I'm just working, beating people up.
Like I always do.
Stop fighting it.
Wait, am I supposed to punch him?
Yeah, I was gonna say it.
How am I supposed to know?
Oh, I'm on a drive clock.
I was gonna say, how the fuck am I supposed to know I'm tagged?
There's a giant clock I'm under.
You cannot win.
You can't fight it.
Okay.
No, I tried to get him!
Jesus Christ, there's so many.
Stop him.
I'm my best.
Oh, I'm 1 HP.
I should have to pay attention.
Let all your troubles fade away.
Bro, there's so many.
I'm...
Oh, my God.
No!
I couldn't!
I was surrounded!
Oh, my God.
That's not fair.
There were 20 people surrounding him that couldn't hit him.
That's actually not fair.
Stop him.
Wait, why can't it...
Oh my gosh, I'm trying to throw my nades.
It won't let me.
There you go.
I wish I can use my...
Use this gadget more often.
Okay.
Relax.
I wish I can lock in.
Yeah.
Got you?
Alright.
There's so many people!
Oh my god.
I'm locking in.
Okay.
My hat's a special.
They make everyone do what I want.
Everyone.
Okay.
We gotta go over.
fade away.
There we go.
I got it.
Jesus, there's so many.
Come on.
Give me that double takedown.
Nice.
Alice will be here soon, that man.
You don't want to miss her, now do you?
Oh, I don't like the sound of that.
Bro, you gotta, you gotta be registered.
Here we go.
Bro, you must be on a list.
There's no way I don't like that You give me the vibes
Bro You better not live near Like any playgrounds in your school Is I don't feel comfortable with you in the neighborhood I 100% do not feel comfortable There we go Does your agent know you're here
He is?
I knew it I was like bro no You give me that vibe you you need a you need to go to a different kind of jail i got your hat
i learned this from the monks to beat mind control thing yeah with my fists this is how you beat mind control thank you for the super chat thank you thank you oh zyko um i'm sure you want to take this uh uh upgrade what is this i like that i feel like the freeze might be good go out and walk back to see him crying what is he crying about fucking pussy just because yeah you got beat up by me what are you crying about i understand what the did i do you're the one he's the one that kidnapped me like hey why why is he crying you kidnapped me first let me adjust some my sound real quick because i hate it if i'm ever mute myself like it like goes my the go xlr pulls down when i mute unmute myself it's so annoying so i'd always be aware of it oh is it because i fucking just buy another hat how do you not have like a stockpile of hats like you just wear one hat every day that's gross man just buy like stockpile it oh go back inside all right let's see this him cry all right is he crying now
that's like right oh he's bald too don't ever try to get in my But you don't understand.
I need you.
I can't wait without you.
He's so pathetic.
Then you lose.
He's so fucking pathetic.
There's no way that's a fitted hat.
My lovely hair.
Oh my god, he's so pathetic.
Yo, yeah, the haircut is crazy.
Yeah, no, no, that is like Ebenezer Scrooge.
Why did you do it?
I just...
Friends, don't drug us, they're friends!
Who taught you that?
This will be so angry.
I've let her down terribly.
Bro, this might as well.
Like, this is just too sad.
You might as well just shave the whole thing up.
Why did you do it?
I just wanted a friend.
A kind of friend that just drug him up and then...
Who taught?
him that exactly who the fuck taught him that all right now we can go save mr freeze's wife
i will say i'm not gonna lie if you are balding in that way just shave it off or like get a hair transplant there's no i'm sorry i don't know like i know like you're like love yourself just do whatever you want to feel but like i will say like if you are balding like just right in the middle,
I feel like at that point, you might as well just shave the entire thing up.
Like, I don't think you can make that work.
I honestly, I'm going to be real, you guys.
I don't think there's any way you can make that work.
You might as well just go full bod or get a hair transplant.
Do what you gotta do at that point.
Like, keeping that hairstyle is just coping.
You got anything to eat?
Sorry, man.
I'm out.
This place is turning to hell.
Turning to hell.
I'm pretty sure it's already out.
What about Danny DeVito?
Yeah, but that's for his acting career.
Do you have an acting career like Danny DeVito?
He needs to keep his hair like that for Sunny in Philadelphia.
No one's going to be able to get close without us seeing.
You could use these sniper rifles.
What the?
Get
the last chance.
My god.
Alright, get this guy out of here.
Like, if you have a career like Daddy DeVito, then you can keep the hairstyle.
Alright, we got another...
We got another voicemail from...
From the clingy Joker.
Where is it?
Where is he?
I almost found everybody, though.
Alright, voicemail number five.
one miss
oh he's on the bargaining side now oh
my god really he's like come on girl you're the love my life i can't live without you bro you know and you know we're end game girl yeah he talks like yeah like honestly yeah all right there he is god even his fucking portrait is creepy How do I have five of his life story already?
Bro, I don't even have the life story.
Like, he has the equivalent life story of Joker.
Like, Harley Quinn doesn't even have that privilege.
How the fuck do I have all your tapes?
I did one quest, and now I know his entire life.
Obsessed from a young age with Lewis Carroll's book, Alice in Wonderland.
embrace a delusion that used an incarnation of a character in a story the the situation ship absolutely thank you the super chat thank you thank you and like using his skills for mesmerism yeah yeah it's like one quest bro and suddenly i know his entire life story often themed around booked on spire and his love of hats and headgear going as far as to implant his hats with mind control chips to amplify his hypnosis skills above all the other headwear COVID's Batman's distinctive cow,
and will stop at nothing to acquire it.
All right.
Patient interview one.
Subject's name, Jervis Tetch.
This is like a one-sided relationship here.
Brought Batman six months ago.
Patient exhibits signs of obsessive compulsion and paranoid schizophrenia.
I feel like 90% of the criminals have schizophrenia.
I need Alice.
Get off me.
Get off me, I'm late.
I'm wearing Alice.
Alice isn't here yet.
Yet?
Just relax, Jervis.
She will be here soon.
Who is Alice for him?
Or is that just like in his head?
Would you like some tea?
No, I'm afraid not.
Let us talk while we wait.
You and I have much in common, Jervis.
I'm trying to hate my room.
It's so, so hot in my room always.
Unfortunately not.
You and I both,
I studied your papers, Jervis.
You are quite brilliant.
Truly an extraordinary mind.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
It's all just chemicals and synapses and rabbits and...
Oh, where is Alice?
You need to focus.
Think about your work for a minute.
You theorize that there is no such thing as free will.
That's true!
Not here.
I tell you what free will is.
With chemicals.
Your formula was really quite brilliant.
That's why I used it.
At least we can create, we can relate in something that had it.
To you?
Wicked girl.
Nasty little thing.
Is she here yet?
My yokey's will is the dragoon's will.
Spoken like a person with me.
no free will I like that oh he does sound like ants in the wise oh god it's so creepy don't make me shout Alice come out where are you oh my god I see registry oh oh who are these people look again oh I don't know who they are oh Please, is Alice here or not?
Look at the first picture.
Look at the dress she is wearing.
Look at the hair.
He just got a random girl's photo?
No, no, no, no.
It can't be Alice.
Alice has nice yellow hair.
What?
Oh.
Blood.
Did he kill her?
I think you know exactly who this is, Mr. Ted.
Oh.
I think you remember the night you lured Stephanie Williams back to your research lab.
offered her tea what happened then no no no what did you do it's okay jervis it's all right to remember how many Alice's were there I can't remember so not all blonde women are Alice bro that's fucked isn't coming is she that all depends on how you I have a little side project that I'm working on.
I could use your help.
I help.
I can't help.
I'll be late.
Stay focused, Jervis.
This facility is old, tired, full of ghosts.
Ghosts?
A figure of speech.
Do not worry.
Arkham Asylum will not exist forever.
Its techniques are old.
Its mission, now dead.
Oh, one man would look at this guy and be like, would trust.
Absolutely, you have a super chat.
Thank you.
I don't know a child.
I feel like a child is not known.
You know, you have to tell children to be like, stranger danger.
Because they can't recognize when a stranger is dangerous.
So you have to be like, all strangers are dangerous.
I need rabbits.
Oh, I ride it.
You and Alice, I know.
You and children aren't that stupid.
You'd be surprised.
You'd be very surprised.
Shall we meet again next week?
Oh, and I took the liberty of having your hats returned.
I assume that will provide all the encouragement you require.
All right, last video.
Last recording.
I must say you have outperformed even my wildest expectations.
You're somewhat both smarter, dumber, and crueller than you think.
the people in my tea party they all behave themselves yes they did jervis i'm very pleased i have just one last request to make of you you must keep it a secret can you keep a secret jervis with enough hats i can stop people remembering secrets that's that count it will oh i need you to pay a visit to warden sharp he needs to come around to my way of thinking join our tea party exactly yeah i don't want to not yet how else will you get to play oh my god he was like i give you the alice you make me the hat assistant for you jervis i had her brought in specially look at her what happened to her oh salis she's here no no what are you doing i need
her of course she'll be oh what happened to her i didn't see any alice though when i was there oh how the okay first of how the hugo strange acquired an alice there's also that that was worry so oh that's gross that's gross that's creepy that's so creepy we're almost there
Hey.
Okay, I did not expect myself to land like that.
Not gonna lie.
I thought I could.
I said I was gonna get the quick time attack, but it did not.
Yeah, I mean, like, that's the thing.
It's like asylum.
How the fuck did he smuggled a child into an insane asylum?
Warden, I thought he was mayor now.
No way could strange get the mayor of Gotham freaking city sent in here.
Oh my god, it's right over here.
Zass, I'll deal with you later.
I have fucking guns aimed at my head.
Protocol 10 will commence in one hour.
It's been one hour, five hours ago.
I don't know about that.
Alright, we're gonna go over here first.
Alright, nice.
I think the flip was a little bit...
Uh...
Just a little bit show just to show up, but that's all right All right, time to answer the phone There's a phone ringing somewhere get ready to run All right, where
All right, where is this phone
Wait, where is it?
Oh, there it is.
I was gonna say where is it?
Why don't I see it anywhere?
Oh my god, I literally just got here.
I hate this man so much.
I actually, I hate this quest.
I hate this quest line so much.
Because it's always like, I just got to my original area.
And then they're like, ring, ring, ring, ring, ring.
Go across the other...
Time to go across the other city.
Yeah, I still do it.
He knows me.
He knows I'll break into the pressure.
Yeah, I don't have the upgrade.
Not yet.
Oh my god, wait.
I might fail this mission.
Oh, please tell me it's...
JK, it's right here.
Oh my god, it's not right here.
Oh, time for...
him the trauma dump again him
playing fair in the casino
whoa all right all right i feel like i've like tried to save this man's wife like four times and i and i always get like some random side quest people are looking for mr freeze really i didn't even know he was in here i feel like i've I've headed back there like at least two to three times.
Yeah, we gotta cancel them, guys.
Someone drop that Google Doc here real quick.
Oh, that sucks, bro.
Alright, attempt number three to get this man's wife back.
The third time's a charm.
Alright, here we go, back to Jokerland.
All right, I'm here.
Let me kill the sniper real quick.
What the hell are you doing?
I told you not to come back empty-handed.
All right, goodbye.
No, I don't have the zip boost.
Oh, am I supposed to find his wife?
You're not distracting me this time.
Not a problem.
Sounds like I need to beat some respect into you.
That's right.
Beat him up.
I ain't getting distracted.
I thought we were supposed to have left by now.
Chill out, man.
It's coming.
Joker wants us to move on into two-faces territory.
Teach that ugly son of a bitch to mess with the boss.
Where is it?
It's a miracle, ain't it?
Yesterday, I figured Joker was a goner.
Today, he's back better than ever.
I'm back to the other side of Joker, man.
A smile back.
It's like there's been this other guy standing in here.
in for it but now the real joker's back on my left so we ready soon we wait for the order what's this oh god damn stupid riddle me this he's by the river is this the river
there's still more riddle than this riddle me this batman
is it like here but check the boats another boat here
like here
is this a boat I don't think this is a boat
I can't see through this
maybe here
is this a doorway to it
no There's no way to get inside that way.
I'm just gonna kill him first.
Get out of here!
Under?
Is there a way to go under it?
Go back and look down the river.
Oh, like here?
Oh, shit!
It's fine.
Batman can't drown.
Oh, like here?
This feels like a ridler thing.
Because it's green.
God, welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Huh.
This entire area is fucking covered by the ridler.
Stupid ridler.
Is it here?
Is it this way or the other way?
Or the other side.
Chat.
Near the goons?
Okay, it's the other way.
way whoops
there's a weak wall I don't see a weak wall yet just stay in the water
there's no weak walls this way so I'll go this side I guess maybe yeah no weak walls here too Maybe this way?
On this side?
Uh-uh.
Oh, is that the weak wall right there?
I see it.
Is it this?
Is that the blue thing?
Enough with the cold.
I get it.
Wee.
Okay, how the fuck?
How do I...
Oh, okay, I gotta pull it.
There you go.
I'll not even pull that.
Wait, maybe on the...
Wait, how the fuck do I get there?
There's a secret in here?
How do I access the secret?
Throw ice in the water.
Oh, my grenade?
Wait, my grenade works on this?
Okay.
Oh shit, wait, it makes up that for!
Hack the boat?
Hack the boat, hack the world.
Wait, I want to hack the boat.
Oh my god, oh it is a secret!
What?
Prison horror, prison freaks.
Prison ghost?
What password can there be?
Darker, effigy, race, freaks, darker freaks,
obsidian, freaks.
Ossidia freaks?
How the fuck did you guys find that out?
Gotham Solem Eviler Solem
Jokers Batman Ravage How the fuck I don't see a city
Eviler It gives me eviler Darker Gotham Prison
Arkham!
Batman again!
Solem!
Oh my god, okay.
Okay, obviously it's not Batman.
It's not Ravage.
Oh my god, there you go, I got City.
City of Freaks, there you go.
There you go, City of Freaks.
What?!
Oh, City of Terror!
Sorry, City of Terror.
It felt like...
I mean, to be fair, it is the City of Freaks.
Here, what is the secret?
Oh, there's a prisoner in here.
What is this?
Wait, they were doing experiments in this area.
Hello?
It won't let me use detective mode.
Oh my god, did I break the game?
Okay, give me a sec.
Alright, I go in.
Oh, there we go.
Wait, I can't.
It doesn't let me use detective mode.
Oh wait, was this a teaser for the next game?
It won't let me.
It's for...
Yeah.
I can't zoom in.
I can't do anything else.
I don't like looking at that.
I don't like that flashes a lot.
Look around.
Am I supposed to look?
I see like the the scarecrow bugs right here.
Oh, right click.
Oh
You fuckers.
You
Fucking baiters.
Okay, thank you, fuckers.
I'm fucking crazy.
You got him.
Fucking crazy.
We did it, guys.
We got it.
This is why you guys don't get free will.
This is another example of why I don't give you free will.
I know you, Erica.
Secure area!
They don't even know I'm here!
How do I secure an area that they don't know I existed?
Alright, pay that to beat you guys up!
Freedom truly is beautiful.
There you go.
Oh, that was an accident, but I'll take that.
What the fuck?
I'm trying to...
Alright, we gotta...
Wait, where is this guy?
There you go.
We gotta get that guy.
I like how he's just there.
He's just been... He's just frozen.
Forget.
Oh, there you go.
I unfrozen.
Wait, that's not why I wouldn't.
Fuck you.
Let's get you out of here.
Get you out of this fight.
Look at...
Get you out of here.
Alright, there you go.
You saw that?
All your friends are dead.
Give me a sec.
Let me...
Hmm.
It's been weeks since I updated my status.
How are people gonna know what I've felt?
There we go.
Check the door here.
Knock, knock.
It's me, Batman.
There's nothing to see in here.
There's nothing here, guys.
I am the knight.
He's like, there's nothing here.
Nothing.
illegal going on here officer and trick or treat
all right i gotta fucking throw this again
all right pull pull pull pull a pizza did anyone order some pizza pizza time i want to play spider-man too but then like um i really I don't know.
I mean, Spider-Man 2 was really fun, but I don't know if it aged correctly.
I don't know if it...
It... Aged well.
Hey, Tokyo.
It's my birthday today.
Glad to be Dragoon for another year.
Happy birthday, Trouble!
And thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Trouble.
Yay!
Happy birthday!
One, two, three.
HD remake no gun doesn't beat paper stick to the guns beat of course gun beats paper what God doesn't beat rock Oh, they're over here You sure this works for three players Well, that's the guns Oh, there's Nora This is going to be a long night Joker sure does know how to pick him.
I'll let them play.
Play Rapper's Scissors.
And then I'll just take these guys down.
Let them have your little game.
Yeah, I went to Calendar, man.
And it was Halloween.
Alright, I'll let them...
See, I'm such a good person.
I let them...
Oh my god, wait.
Oh, wait, I love that.
Oops.
Okay.
Let's get these guys out of the way.
Whoa!
I'm fucking zooming!
Look at me go!
That's right!
Wait.
I'll get this guy out here.
Boom!
He's gonna do this real fast.
That's right.
Get you out of here in this fight.
Oh wait, you have a gun.
Nah, you don't get a gun.
Alright, take him out, too.
Alright.
Look at me go.
Look at that combo.
You see that combo I did?
Batter on ice!
Wee!
Oh, shit, wait.
There we go.
Wee!
I like this kava.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Wee.
And again.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, you're not getting that.
Wee.
And again.
That's right.
For my amusement only.
I wonder if I can actually kill with this.
Is it just stun?
Yay!
Combo!
He's trying like, where is she?
Is it stun only?
Unlucky.
It's unlucky.
If it's just, I guess if it's just stun only.
I wonder if I can Let's see it.
What would be a fun way to kill you?
Oh, I know All right, watch this.
I'm doing aim practice I'm gonna do watch this guys and then you turn.
Oh shit.
No, you turn
Don't worry.
I got this
I got this guys.
Oh my god, where am I going?
Yeah!
I did it.
Drop kick.
We did it, guys.
I should really un-invert that.
Freeze's wife is safe.
I should tell him.
Wait.
I told you.
I got it.
Wait, I'm just supposed to like look at her and be like, by the way, she's safe.
It's about the end result.
Guys, I got it to work.
Rose and date.
Yeah, she looks pretty frozen.
Alright, where is he?
Okay, I gotta go back to him.
Don't move, Nora.
I'm gonna inform your husband that you're safe.
There you go.
Try and pop that balloon.
Like, I could have lied to him.
I could have been, like, yeah, she's safe.
And, like, how would he know?
How would he know?
Uh, Ale.
Alejandro, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hola.
What?
I always, like, forget which way I'm supposed to do this.
Oh, my God.
I have to go that back way.
Can you not unfreeze that for me, bro?
Sorry, I forgot.
He's Mr. Freeze, not Mr. Unfreeze.
I have to go to, like, the other side.
I have to go to the back door, man.
So annoying.
What?
Oh, I have to do this again?
I'm lucky.
Alright.
Hello, Mr. Freeze.
Found your wife.
She's okay.
She's still frozen, but she's okay.
I found her freeze.
She's safe.
Nora, where is she?
She was locked up in Warehouse 5B in the Falcone shipping yard.
She's safe, Victor.
You can go to her.
Thank you, Batman.
I doubted you.
And now look who's an idiot for not giving me my fucking medication.
Not giving me the goddamn cure.
now don't you we're fine is it related to Nora I
can talk to him more bro he apologized him apologizing isn't gonna fix my super aides I am preparing a solution to remedy whatever oh what about me what about the damage on me thank you for finding Nora I am preparing a solution to remedy whatever damage the clown yeah what about solution for my fucking super aids okay oh my god my fucking wife who's not technically not even alive all
right let's see where do we go so many little missions around here okay there is what is this one do we it Is that gadget important?
Distress for there.
Is that an important one?
What do I get out of this?
Oh my god.
It's our little beach episode.
We have so many filler.
Start with a close one.
Alright, I'll do that.
It's like right below me.
Yeah, it is.
That's right.
It's me.
What the fuck did I do?
Bro, I never seen that move before.
Yeah.
Oh, that's new.
Oh, I broke the combo.
I broke the combo again.
Oh, I think it's just a combo, right?
Every time I do the combo, it gives me like...
new ass moves there.
Oh, I broke it again.
That's right.
Remember to go to the Wayne Hospital and look for private care.
Here's the card to the nearest hospital.
And remember to request for the Wayne care.
Alright, let's grab armor.
Uh, we'll do combat.
Here?
I assume it's here.
Remember to request for the Wayne healthcare plan.
Bane?
What?
Bane, you're here?
What are you doing here, Bane?
Oh, this one.
Oh wait, that's the other Bane.
That's before.
You knew it would not kill me.
I wasn't trying to.
I'm in no mood for a fight.
What are you doing here?
Dr. Young's Titan formula.
I also managed to send some off Arkham Island before you stop.
Yeah, you skipped Leg Day.
I know.
Penguin had his own Titan guards.
How much more did Joker send out?
Too much.
That is why I am here.
I will not allow the Basura of this city to abuse the Titan.
Dr. Young used me to create it.
It is my duty to destroy what remains.
Wait, are we...
Are we friends now?
If you try anything...
Oh my god, best friends forever.
Let's make friendship places.
This, Bane?
I'll forget about the fact you broke my back.
Of course.
Each container has a radio beacon built in.
There were 12 containers left in this city.
We take six each.
Then we meet back here.
I'm ahead of you, Bane.
You find your six.
I'll take care of what's left.
You've got some catching up to do.
Oh, we're making a little bet here.
Don't make me regret that.
Alright, connecting to the back computer.
Work with Bane, three Titan containers remaining.
Oh, wait, I did most of them.
Oh, wait.
That was the one where I was, like, just casually destroyed.
Oh, my God.
There's one back in the sub.
I didn't realize there was one here.
Okay, that's the entrance for that.
I gotta figure out how to get in there.
Okay, I gotta figure out how to...
I mean, I could technically...
Is that the...
Okay, I could go...
No, I'll go this way.
All right.
A good thing I did some of them.
I'll do this one because there's two over here.
and then we'll just go through that station and then like just find a way across this and then just go left.
What is it?
Are you afraid you will fail?
All right.
Jesus, Chris.
At least he's not Absolute Bane.
Apparently I found out the Absolute series are just like Darksides fan fiction.
You know, it's like how Adventure Time where the Ice King made Fiona and Cake.
So like the Absolute series is literally just dark-sized little own fan fiction of how he like his own OC's his own like my original character do not steal he's not Batman okay he's absolute Batman it's different he has little fan fiction in prison from Burke to serve his dead father sentence Bane was raised inside a heroic invisions of a Santa Uh,
Priscan prison.
Since the event, remember that beta's turned over and you leave.
Oh my god!
He's like, um, you're out of line, but you are, right?
Darkside wrote some, so.
Darkside should be a writer, man.
He should be like, uh, Stephanie Myers, when she wrote her fan fiction.
Um, oh my god, what was Twilight based off of again?
Oh, no, that's not Twilight.
Um, it was, what's your name?
The girl, the lady that...
The author that did the BDSM novel.
Fuck, it's been so long.
She fell off so hard.
I have 50 Shades of Grey.
What?
No.
It's not feeding time.
Come on.
No?
No.
I'm not getting another noise complaint.
But yeah, 50 Shades of Grey is actually based off of a fan fiction from Twilight.
So Bane should do that, bro.
Not Bane, sorry.
Dark Side.
Bro, you can...
You don't need...
bro you can make your own stories you don't need Batman
I need to turn on aircon in a second
I have to turn on the aircon I should freeze some of the water water's too hot all right um let's see what was I on talking about before I talked about there oh yeah I was just trying to say yeah you should just he just create his own series but yeah bane is like like um he's like a sponsor now bro he's like in part of alcoholics anonymous he's like like don't worry bro i too was on the hard shit but now but now i'm here to help you look at me i got my one year coin i'm one year sober he says when He's clearly not sober.
And he's like, guys, don't do Titan.
It ruined my life.
Anyway, hit me up, bro.
Yeah, I don't think he looks clean, guys.
He definitely does not look clean.
No, no.
I mean, like, wait, actually, I'll go here first.
So now I can go over here and then do this mission.
too right after it's totally natural guys the green stuff you see from my skin i just drank a lot of mountain dew guys that's
really it that's what it is i just happen to drink a lot of mountain dew that's why i'm glowing green i feel like if you're gonna try and like tell people to not do Titan?
You know, you gotta be a good example.
Wee.
Won't he die if he doesn't take the venom?
It's alright.
He can just wean it off, you know?
He's just going through withdrawals.
It's like how you just start drinking less and less alcohol instead of going full cold turkey.
It's actually going full cold turkey is really bad for you.
You have to like slowly get off of it.
Like, depending on what you're addicted to, it's actually, like, incredibly bad to go full cold turkey.
But this is, like, a side mission, wasn't it?
I was gonna say, how did I do silent here?
You can actually die from going full cold turkey.
That's the crazy part.
That's the- actually- that's the scary part.
You can literally die from doing it.
Because your body's so used to, like, whatever you're addicted to,
uh that like it's really bad for your body and the substation the subway station is here great but you saw what it did the joker didn't you he puffed up like some kind of monster yeah but he had to inject it didn't he we're safe just god uh where is it it was here freaking titan crates when the boss sent me out How do I get here,
though?
I figured out how to get to this one.
It's outside?
Oh, that is inside.
It looks like it's inside.
It's actually outside?
Brian, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh.
Okay.
I guess it's this way.
So, oh my god, this is so confusing.
So, net maneuver.
Yeah, it looks like it was inside.
Is it here?
Oh, it was here.
Okay.
Alright, I'll just get these guns out of the way.
Alright.
He's dodging my bat.
They can just do it.
You can just dodge my banner and I like that?
Fuck you.
That's right.
Ice smash.
That's for dodging.
Okay, let me do this and it'll take your goddamn phone call.
Oh, let me tag it again.
The double tag.
There we go.
Alright, where is his stupid phone call?
God, he's so obsessed with me.
I have too many villains obsessed with me.
My phone and answer it quick, Batman.
What if I was in the bathroom, bro?
I gotta pee.
Oh my god.
Okay, oh, it's here.
Okay, I was gonna sit.
Alright.
Oh, it's one minute.
Oh, this is gonna be tight.
Okay.
One minute's not a lot of time.
Okay, we're gonna have to...
I'm gliding!
Not as fast as I would like!
Oh, there it is.
Alright, I'll take this call.
How many times is he gonna call me?
I feel like the payoff is not gonna be worth it.
He leaned forward and it's gonna be like...
It's gonna fall out.
What's the word when it falls expectations in the end?
It'll be very anticlimactic.
This does not feel like it's worth it.
This is why you're an unmemorable Batman villain.
It's why no one remembers you except for the Batman games.
They had Z-list villain.
All right, we gotta go back to doing these.
Wee!
All right, we're ahead across the city now.
Uh, I can't wait for the third, playing the third game when we get the car.
And we can just drive over the villains.
We can just drive over everywhere.
It'll be a lot faster.
I never watched the Gotham TV show.
I know it's like...
Because it was on the CW?
Uh...
The only...
It was on the CW, right?
The Gotham show?
And the only, like, CW show I watched was...
Uh...
Was Supernatural.
Oh, was it on Fox?
Oh, I was thinking about Arrow.
Or...
I was thinking about...
Aw, I was thinking about...
Uh...
Oh, and Riverdale.
Yeah, and Riverdale.
I was thinking about the Green Arrow show.
I heard...
I heard about it.
Alright, we gotta find the other Titan.
Thank God I did those three earlier.
Bane's sponsor, Amy, sounds like a plotline from Harley Quinn.
I would say Harley Quinn Bane is my favorite Bane.
Out of all the Bane iteration.
He's just, I don't know.
For me, he's like, he's like the most Bane.
I know, he might not be the most Bane for you guys, but for me he's the best Bane they've ever made.
He's so, he's so fucking stupid.
That's stupid.
I feel like the first, literally I'm only watching Harley Quinn for Bane.
Because the newest seasons of Harley Quinn is so fucking bad.
But the...
But like, Bane makes it all watchable for me.
Jesus, bro.
Where is it?
Yeah, he's actually the best character in the show.
But where is this?
It's like here.
Oh, there it is.
It's not toxic.
Is it or radioactive or whatever?
Goodbye.
Alright.
Oh, I didn't want to smash you, but that's fine.
Okay, the ice gadget is so useful, not gonna lie.
Mm-hmm.
How do I kill you?
Oh, I'll just do this.
This is the easiest.
It's the fastest.
So how would I put you in the hospital?
Cool, guys, don't look at explosions.
Boom.
Wait, did it work?
Yeah, it did.
Alright, one Titan container left.
How do I get in here, actually?
A steel mill.
How do I get in the steel mill?
Here?
Where's the door at?
What the fuck is that door?
Oh, there.
Joko make me his right-hand guy when I drag that point here.
Who said that?
You think you're the one That's gonna kill Batman?
Really?
You, goon number five.
You're gonna be the one That's gonna stop it all.
Really, you.
That's cute, buddy.
That's so cute.
Wee!
There we go.
I got the door Goodbye You think he got the door I'll cover the door Yeah, you're gonna cover the door Guys, I don't think he covered the door It's alright He's dead Oh, what I thought so much I forgot I only have combat armor I was like, he can't, they can't give me I have so much armor I forgot,
he did it, he covered the He actually did it.
Oh my god, got it.
That's crazy.
Kappa, that madman.
He covered the door.
Alright, let's get this guy out of here.
Whee!
Alright.
Joker go number 5-1.
He actually did it, that madman.
Yeah?
Did you do it?
There we go.
Oh shit!
I still have my nades!
That's right.
We got high now.
I don't know where the door is anymore.
Oh wait, there he is.
There he is.
They covered the door.
They're still covering, guys.
Oh shit.
Oh shit, I'm one.
He's still covering the door, though.
He's still doing it.
There we go.
That's right.
No more doors.
Don't let him cover up the doors again.
Oh, see, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I went to SDCC this year to promote a Gotham show.
They had high zip line across the city.
Oh, that's so cool.
A copy of the new...
That's like good memorabilia, too.
Also, JP, uh, thank you for, welcome to the command farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Remember as a hero, goal number five, when you covered that door.
Oh, now they teach me this move.
I'm sorry, brazo.
I can't come to the...
Oh, shit!
I'm trying to announce something called secret from Mr. J.
So I can't find you what it is.
Or, I'm keeping the seal now for your best confrontation.
Bro, I was just wanting to listen to the lore.
I was just trying to listen to the lore, man.
I was supposed to know it would...
They would know I'm here.
Also, I mean, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
There you go.
Remember to go to the Wayne Private Hospital.
Alright, let's see.
We need the ice for this.
also.
Holy shit!
Wait.
It's like back... Wait.
It's back here.
The Titans is over there.
Yeah.
I didn't see... I just missed the Titan.
Oh, wait.
Not the back, though.
Uh, got all the Titan.
The Bane's gonna be so proud of me.
Now that all the Titan containers are destroyed, I should go back to Bane and see how he's doing.
Alright, we'll do that later.
Oh, we gotta...
and then what oh whoops I just heard from my dad he's been summoned to City Hall strange is requesting that emergency protocol 10 is activated what does the emergency 10 is I forgot to do a security measure strange told the High Council he had failed to stem the use of illegal weapons within the prison weapons he this was his plan all along it certainly looks that way I can wait I don't actually have to pull it I'm patient enough like I just have to go here right I'll just wait hello okay i was gonna say if i not can i not climb this i don't know it's not that fast not gonna lie okay now it gets a little scary now i can see why i have to pull it yeah i have to pull it here i mean i can see now I don't know why I had to do it.
But other than that, it's not, like, too threatening.
Alright, I can wait.
Did you see the Joker just now?
Yeah, he looked okay, didn't he?
Open sesame!
How the hell did that happen?
Today?
Well, good.
So, did he find the cure or what?
Did he do it?
The last thing I heard was the doctors couldn't save him.
Quinn even had me torture some lady doctor to find a cure.
That's not cool.
Torch is not cool only when I do it though, because I'm a good person Well, who cares he's back the Joker's back Well, he's alive.
I'll say that He's not really there.
He's he's alive We still Okay
Wait, we can't have that.
That's fucking right.
We can't have you get the guns.
Get out of here.
Wait, I was trying to get you.
Get your ass out of here.
No guns.
If I can't shoot, you can't shoot out of here.
That's right.
You ain't killing nobody.
Wait, we gotta get that.
this guy out here.
Oh.
We gotta do a beat down, I guess.
Oh, shit.
There you go.
No gun for you!
Oh, no.
I'm trying to do a beat down, but, like, everyone else is not letting me.
I would love to do a beat down on you right now, bro.
Okay.
There you go.
There's my beat down.
down.
Your turn!
No guns allowed!
Only I get to use gadgets.
I'm Batman.
As you can see, I'm looking much better.
In fact, ooh, I think I'm looking better than ever.
It's crazy what makeup can do.
Look, look, be up your surgeon.
Now, well, here's the thing.
Answers don't give you everlasting satisfaction.
Sometimes you need to brace yourself for disappointment.
Now, think about it.
Imagine your favorite TV show.
You've been through it all.
The ups, the downs, the crazy coincidences, and then bang.
They tell you what it's all about.
Would you be happy?
Does it make sense?
wait is Batman the one is joke that's not the real Joker right it's a double and Joker's the one that's filming no hostage yeah no surrender I know it sounds like suicide but listen whatever happens I'll be right behind you I don't think that's the real Joker that's I don't think that's the real Joker.
There's no way.
Oh yeah, this is definitely Harley Quinn's office.
Like, you can't just get better.
Like, what the fuck?
Did he get, like, a plastic surgeon too?
It's like, what's his name?
Chris, uh, what was her name?
Courtney?
I don't know.
The, the, the, oh my God, what was it?
The Kardashians.
Kim Kardashian's mom?
like she had like a crazy insane plastic surgery recently where she looks like she's 50 instead of like i don't know 70 or like the special filter oh yeah did you guys see that tweet of this um of some guy in china made like the fucking e-girl filter wait i gotta show you guys this actually reminded me i saw this on twitter i was like holy shit like take the crazy ass filters now that The filters that exist today is insane.
Like, it actually literally changes your gender.
I'm pretty sure I saved it.
Because I was like...
Alright.
Oh, apparently it's not in real time.
But even if it's not in real time and they did this via post, that's so crazy.
Yeah.
Someone did a community note and said, oh, this isn't in real time.
It takes, like, roughly one minute to generate the clip.
But even the fact, even if it takes one minute for like a five second clip, that's still really good time.
Because if they can do that now, if they can, even though it takes time to generate this, eventually they can only do it.
They can do it real time.
It's getting there.
Yeah.
Eventually it'll be real time.
Because the fact is just basically trying to like fine tune it until it's real time.
That's insane.
That's actually insane.
The filter goes fucking hard.
And new girls weren't real.
The first step is VTubers.
The second step is flesh.
You can't wait to catfish the homies.
And since...
Because eventually, eventually, it'll be real time.
You're right.
Just add delay.
Just add a five minute delay on OBS.
You're so right.
eventually all right
that's right the stream is there's a five minute delay on stream so i can get my filters to work
let me explain to you what's going on the joker is winning you and your boss are losing now we want the joker to keep winning So you're gonna tell us everything we need to know about Two-Face's plans.
You probably don't want to.
I get that.
So we're gonna have to convince you.
Screw you!
Wait, whose boss is that?
Whose goon is that?
I don't know who's goon this is.
You can still hear me, right?
Two-Face.
Oh, it's Two-Face!
He's black and white.
Alright, give me a sec.
Apparently...
I'm gonna drop you.
I have to beat up the heart.
Yeah.
The Harley bots.
I forgot about that.
I didn't hear this first sentence.
He started melting before he even touched the hot stuff.
You ever smelled melting flesh?
No, no.
Most people haven't.
Let me paint you a picture.
First, it smells like meat on a barbecue.
You know, burning skin, fat, meat.
Then...
It reaches the bones.
That's the nasty bit.
Maybe he's immune to acid.
Like Joker.
I guess it was all kind of...
It could happen.
Because he screamed pretty much up to the point.
It's like a 1%.
He could be the 1%.
Who cares?
You're gonna tell us what Two-Face is up to.
Right?
Oh, okay.
To be fair, this seems like Goon number 240.
I feel like Two-Face would not tell him anything.
Oh shit, I'm supposed to save him!
Um...
Oh my god, I did it.
I...
I'm a hero!
I forgot to...
Imagine if I didn't save him?
That was a close call.
you were so yeah yeah it was that would have been so awkward I'm a hero he almost died it's but I'm a hero wait I'll be back I gotta I gotta deal with the heart of the actually I don't know if he despawns if I don't come back how do I destroy these again
How do I destroy these?
Oh, this.
There you go.
I saved your life.
Oh, it is a turf war.
That's it?
Okay.
I don't get anything out of it.
Anyway, I gotta destroy the other one first, too.
There you go.
What?
What happened?
I thought we cool!
I thought
we...
For a second!
I quit boiling in water.
Okay, good.
God, unappreciative.
Talk about ungrateful.
So ungrateful.
Yeah, get out of here.
Sure, let them boil you.
He flipped the coin.
Bro fucking flipped the coin.
Don't be naive.
Yeah, the coin was... he flipped heads.
Get out of here.
Why is there... is this a puzzle?
I swear to God.
Okay, it's this.
I knew it.
Wait, a two-face gun is two-face.
saying it ain't so.
Yeah, where am I supposed to go?
Alright.
That'll work.
Don't worry, I'll get there eventually.
Slow and steady.
Okay.
You have to do this, I guess.
What?
There we go.
I'm pulling!
Oh my god, this is taking so long.
The ledge is literally blocking me.
I've hacked into the council CCTV.
The council members are coming back.
They don't look happy.
Are they ever happy though?
That they never believed Protocol 10 would need to be activated.
But they gave him permission, didn't they?
Am I slowly heading over?
All 10 will commence in 30 minutes.
You all have specific orders for this situation.
Follow them.
Do you still need an answer?
Bruce, I don't like this.
Be careful.
How do I get to the other side?
There's no thing to pull.
Yeah, I'm stuck.
Oh, is it lying?
Oh, it is the...
Okay, I was going to say, am I supposed to line launch you this?
Yeah.
That's right.
Kitten aided.
Yeah, I was gonna say, what the fuck?
Where am I supposed to go now?
Flow and steady.
Oh my god, it's a bat.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright, it's batter-on time.
I practice for this.
Okay, wait.
I matched.
I should have inverted.
I still forgot to invert.
U-turn!
Okay, it's right here.
There's the hole.
I'm still on inverted controls, but that's okay.
Okay, let's...
Um...
Okay.
There you go.
Alright, here you go.
Now...
should be fine.
It's so much.
Who would have?
Okay.
But like, what is in...
Who is...
Okay.
I need to know.
Like...
Oh my god.
I need to know.
Like, who is it for?
Inverted controls.
What kind of sick fuck is like into that?
A batterang will hold enough charge to overload the...
Oh, I forgot to fucking electrocute it.
There you go.
For real.
Realism.
Flight sim enthusiast.
I hate to break it to you, but not all of you are going to be pilots.
Wrong.
Yeah, where are you going to fly a plane?
Don't crush their dreams.
There's a pilot short.
I wonder why.
I wonder why there's a pilot short.
shortage right now.
And they ain't looking too good in the flying community.
And you'll never be bad.
Because I played video games to escape reality.
It's not like I actually want to be Batman.
Let's see.
Oh, wait.
This is a shortcut.
Wait, what?
Oh, it's here.
I came from... Wait, which... Where did I come from here?
Yeah.
Alright.
And we're literally Batman.
I don't know what this is for, but I guess I'll do it.
What is this for?
What?
I don't understand.
Like, I see a hostile, but I don't understand what it's for, though.
Oh, it's for a trophy?
What the fuck?
It's all right.
You're safe.
You're lucky.
Oh, it's... I forgot I was here before.
Believe me, Doctor.
Yeah, you're not killing this armor.
This armor was, like, $5 million.
What's been happening?
I did what you said.
I stayed out of sight and kept an eye on what they were to they've been placing things on the what do you mean jokie she swung her bet sounds like it means i get plus one will it work do i look worried worried no sick very you look terrible don't worry about me get back to wherever you've been hiding i'll deal with the mines oh all right i gotta deal with the mines now
and the steel man
Apache, thank you thank you, thank you thank you thank you thank you the real Joker's back thank God man I mean who the hell wants Harley in charge between you and me she's none of you yes ha ha what hey my dear why don't you go and fight black man while i make a daring escape you guys better hope she didn't hear that enough screwing around get these oh that's a lot of that's a lot of criminals oh that's a lot that's actually a lot of criminals
Okay, he has the proximity mine, so I'll kill him first
Okay, it's still hitting me, okay, that's cool No, I didn't Oh, where am I?
I could be anywhere Okay, that's alright
Oh my god, he has a shotgun.
Guys, I'm...
Guys, it ain't looking so good for me.
It's not looking so good for me, guys.
Stub!
Oh, wait.
I tried just again.
Okay, I'll actually stub the stab.
Yeah, I was, I think, I think he got me.
Like...
That's what he said.
Man, you should have seen his face.
The point blank.
That thugs armed with proximity mines.
Bro, what the- that is not safe.
Look at me.
I'm gorgeous.
So what's the deal with Jay?
That does not look safe.
It's a freaking miracle.
Yesterday looked like crap.
Today?
The real Joker's back.
Thank God.
Yeah, I don't think that's- I think it's a double ganging.
What is he doing?
Okay, my dear.
Why don't you go and fight Batman?
Can I do this?
No, he's not under me.
What do I stealth this?
What the fuck?
I'm trying to figure out how to stealth this, but I don't know.
It doesn't look too good.
joke will make me his right-hand guy when I drag that pointy and freak through the boss no this is this this is not look stealthable I think I there's only one thing I can do the boss wants this place kept safe no problem I can tell you it absolutely is not the dokiway That's for sure I could tell you it's not via the dokiway
I'm stuck in arkham city and joker still telling me what to do nothing changes
Oops Silent takedown Dokey smash.
So silent.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Give me a sec.
Let me open this vent real quick.
No, I'm not.
Guys, there's a lot of people with guns here.
You think they know?
Who's actually telling the truth?
The mind's...
Don't blow us up.
Silent!
They walked away.
It's not my fault.
Did he get up?
Wait, I could just bait him in here.
Yeah, I'm right here.
Wait, I just need him to turn around.
Wait, as soon as they turn around.
He's making us look stupid.
Watch this.
Shut the hell up.
We need to keep looking or we're all dead.
Show yourself, chicken.
Yeah, show yourself.
Oh, shit.
Serpentine.
Get closer.
Yeah, watch this, bro.
Oh, what the fuck?
He's trying to smoke me out like a rat.
Oh, yeah.
right?
Seals!
You do?
I may have to drop you.
Seals!
Yeah, it's over here.
Where did he go?
Where did he go, guys?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, I'm right here.
Yeah, you want to come over here.
Yeah, that's right.
really where could he be
oh shit I thought he was on the other no
I couldn't see I couldn't see the whole we did it guys what HP and energy I thought he was on the other side because of my x-ray thing when you're crouch it looked like he was on the other side of the window okay let's get the ballistic arm i think we need it oh you should have lost that look at that that's called stealth right here with the power of stealth that's how you do it where am i supposed to go okay is this way i remember he was like guarding this door Or the power of stuff by my side.
I hear you, buddy.
We don't.
I'm in your walls.
How do I get out of here?
Wait, what?
What the fuck is this bed for?
Oh, it's for nothing.
I thought I could do something with this bed.
I just...
Oh, wait.
Oh, bot.
Can I?
Is there actually something there?
Yeah, I was going to say, that's not how I sleep before.
But yeah, that's not going to lead me anywhere.
All right, I'm trying to figure out how to get out of here, though.
Oh, like here, maybe?
Is there another exit here?
I think you saw me poking my head up.
Nah.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh.
No, it's not.
You're just seeing things.
I'm in a box.
Stupid.
Oh, shit!
Smoke!
Stealth!
I did not see the fucking mine.
That's smart.
That was a smart sniper.
How are they?
This is a trap, isn't it?
This feels like a trap.
Oh, yeah, no, you're not stupid enough for this.
You have a PhD.
Alright.
Enough talking.
Wait.
You can talk.
Or...
Nope.
talking JK respect women oh wow wait oh wait no no no this is equality here I beat up a defenseless sniper too all right mislocate the freeze technology stolen but wait how do I find that
what how do I get that here how do I get this anyway
Do I just keep going this way?
Is this through the waste exchange?
Yeah, this fist is rated E for everyone.
I don't even know how to get this.
Maybe another entrance, maybe.
I don't know.
I'll keep it.
Actually, yeah.
Wait, does she say anything new?
That's some strong-ass lipstick.
Stop doing that.
I'm going to tell Mr. Jack.
He's going to what?
He's sick.
Well, he's going to be sick.
Don't you dare.
Look, I'm doing dialogue option.
What are you?
Alright.
That's strong-ass lipstick, girl.
Where did you get that?
Go this way.
I think I go this way.
I guess this way.
Gova, thank you a 20 gift and ships.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
Also, Apache, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, there's the hack.
I can hack this now.
Might as well.
I mean, the ruler did spend his entire life savings on this.
I might as well entertain him a little bit.
Tough hen.
Like, he gets nothing out of this.
the bat and thinks he can take something for a hat oh that means catwoman's gonna be here for next
what the hell's his problem didn't he give us these guns in the first place i get this guys yeah i thought he wasn't joking with me too but don't you think that's kind of crazy who spends billions of dollars building a prison oh you got a point hey we're not the asylum are you well I was man old Sharpie was weird too just like strange yeah I heard a bunch of patients died I'm so smart my brain is fucking huge sure he's an idiot but he convinced an entire city to build this place didn't he and he hired strange who gave us military-grade weapons so what are you saying I'm saying I didn't trust Shaw I don't trust strange I don't like this all right double-checked down boom that's right oh shit oh my god they're getting the guns oh my god there's three guns okay oh god they got the guns Okay.
All right, we gotta get, make sure you don't get the guns.
That's right, get over here.
Oh wait, wrong one, but that, I'll take those.
All right, why don't you guys get frozen?
And I'll deal with you.
One on one!
All right, now can Aura walk over?
Ice smash!
Alright.
Um...
This way.
Is it this way?
No.
This way.
To here?
Where the fuck?
Hack the Harley costume?
What, this one?
The one I just broke?
I broke it though.
Yeah, I don't think I can hack this.
Yeah, I'm just listening to the radio.
Oh, up there in the room above.
Oh, okay, I was gonna say, guys, I think it's broken, broken.
This one?
Oh, this one!
Wait, that's a robot?
What?
We created a robot?
Wait, is that what the Joker is now?
Nope, I just listened to the radio.
I'm sorry, bozo.
I can't come to the phone right now.
I'm probably asked to win something.
Warden.
Quincy Sharp.
Huh?
Is that a mannequin?
Oh, I thought it was a robot.
Yeah, no, I noticed the other outfit.
I just thought it was like a...
I hacked this.
Zoom in on the ground.
oh shit what she's pregnant oh my god his pull-up game is weak bro he's dying let him oh my god he got she got jokered oh my god that's crazy you would think like him dropping an acid meant like, you know, that's never going to be possible.
I would feel like the acid would like ruin like, would ruin it, you know?
My.
I don't know.
I feel like the acid would like sort of destroy any possibility of Harley Quinn getting Pregante.
Life finds a way.
Oh, yeah, no, the kid isn't gonna be okay.
No, 100%.
The kid ain't right.
I would agree.
Yeah, see, he's still sick.
I knew it.
There's no way he got better.
Where is it?
Because I know he's dead by the third game.
Manors cost nothing, Batman.
Please wouldn't go amiss.
I mean...
if you wanted to be cured so badly you only had to ask that's not a mirror he's doing this little fucking role-play game with this doppelganger i'm gonna like run through that and i can run through the area because it's not a mirror there's always something to learn let's start with getting your ass kicked 101 seconds out there's no way that's not a mirror i'm literally gonna Yeah,
I knew it.
That's not a mirror.
Unknown.
Why can't I know you?
Wait, you have no bone.
Wait a minute.
You have no bone.
Where are your bones, Joker?
That's sick.
Where's your bones?
your bones hang on did i say me i meant me and these guys what the oh i was gonna say i'm quick to fight ghosts i'm gonna say oh my god i'm gonna fight ghost now
yeah dodge this oh it's this guy it's no hand all right we gotta get rid of no hands right real quick
oh my god bro i'm trying to get rid of this guy all right we'll freeze joker for now wait are they unlimited until i beat up joker i just gotta know before i do this
are they unlimited until i beat up joker guys important.
No?
Okay, that's good.
Jesus Christ, there's so many people.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Boom!
That's right, Joker, or whoever you are.
I know it's not you.
I know that Joker has bones.
Who are you?
Jesus.
Yeah.
God damn it.
The knife is throwing me off my groove.
Bro, I'm pre... Oh!
I had to hold.
Why?
Oh my god, there's so many people.
Yeah, it's twin, bro.
Wait, I got test ethereal.
Oh, I can't go up.
I was gonna see.
I was gonna say, I know that's not a mirror.
There's no way.
That's actually crazy.
He's like, okay, I'm gonna do this and I'm gonna make sure.
Alright, make sure, like, you follow my every move.
That's actually crazy.
That's how committed he is.
Oh my god, I was in the middle of this shit.
There you go.
Yoink.
Again!
That's right!
Oh, the combos!
Yeah, no, you dodged this!
That's right!
Oh my god, I'm insane!
Freeze!
Oh my god, nuclear bomb hits!
Holy shit!
Where was he beating him?
Where did he find him?
Actually, where the fuck did he find this man?
Ultra, son.
Beat down.
Oh, my God.
This guy is interrupting my beat down.
This guy is actually interrupting my beat down right now.
All right, there we go.
Titan, man.
And I hit nothing.
Titan Shockwave!
All right, nice.
At least the car will help me.
Yeah.
All right, now I got the double stun.
God damn it!
I'm trying to stun this man!
Go get out of here!
Titan smash!
Get out of here, Joker!
Stun!
Oh my god, I'm trying to like get to this guy right now.
Joker, please!
This was a one-on-one!
Please!
Oh my god, I'm so annoyed.
I'm so annoyed.
I'm literally, oh my, I'm trying to fucking...
Try to have my own 1v1.
Oh my god, and then he has a knife now?
oh my god jesus oh no oh no this is bad this is so bad i gotta freeze him or it's too late oh my god this is so bad okay one two three beat down okay i got him slam dunk it's just you and me joker
That's right.
Get out of here!
Thank God the big man picked him picked his goons up.
What are you with?
Your Batman just did it.
Yeah, me, him, and my 1 million gadgets.
Any last requests?
How about a joke?
Huh?
Let him go.
Tahlia!
My third girlfriend.
Tahlia, what are you doing?
I represent the great Reish Algoon, head of the demon, master of the League of Assassins.
Well, bully for you.
Free Batman, and we will give you the secret of immortality.
My ex is having a meaning.
Don't be unstoppable.
What?
Oh no, my ex is working together.
Oh no, my worst nightmare.
Ha ha ha ha.
Do we have a deal?
Oh, shut up.
Oh.
We offered you this chance, Batman.
Now follow your heart.
Ex is conspiring.
Oh, wait, she put a tracker on.
How did Joker not see this?
it it's like glowing are we not done yet ivy i told you that thing with the flowers wasn't my fault you know it i know it you should have watered them you said you would water them now there's only one left and strange has it sealed and is oh i let her plants die i think we can strike i'm a bad bro cat woman it's not very good with plants you're just the girl to help if you get me in there I'll get your plant.
I should kill you.
But you won't.
Oh, I'm kind of disappointed.
Damn.
Come on, I came all the way here.
No kiss?
Yeah, toxic Yuri and toxic Yowie.
I...
You know what?
Okay.
You know what I think it is?
And I think I'm right.
I think it's Clayface.
Because we have yet to bump into Clayface.
And like Clayface doesn't have bones.
He's literally made out of clay.
I'm pretty sure.
You guys don't have to tell me if I'm right or not.
But like that's my game theory.
That's my theory.
My game theory.
Yeah.
Because I was like Why the fuck are you bones?
that's what happened to your bones the the surgeon take your fucking bones you know like because you wanted to have fun like it was they were supposed to go with the ribs but then you went a little overboard like I was like what the fuck wait a minute that don't make no sense and like you know we I'm pretty sure that was like literally them it was not a mirror like there was no way that was the mirror and the cutscene cut it so that I can't even check if it is a mirror or not it was yeah it was just supposed to be the bottom rib and but the surgeon got a little too had a little too much fun I'm what that's looking right me yeah do I have any special yet no I don't
I'm surprised two-faces oh shit okay you know okay wait we got it we gotta go we we don't worry I'm faster than a bullet do you though oh my god they might actually get me with them right I'm climbing this fucking wall I'm literally one HP call it in tiger command we're in sector two we were attacked the vault
Guys, I'm 1 HP.
This is not good.
Do I get any heals?
Do they have guns?
I barely have anything.
Oh, wait.
What the fuck is my bolas?
Is this like my bataran?
Does this kill or is it just a stun?
I need a no.
Oh, how come the detectives?
Was it killer or a stun?
Is, do you think he's tied up?
He does not look like he's tied up.
What's this?
The cow tops?
He must die from there.
How is he dodging it?
It's coming from high ground.
Okay.
When he starts crawling.
Okay, that's good.
I don't know.
I thought like, you know, wait, is he still...
Oh, shit.
I got slapped.
I made it so far, too!
Oh my god, how...
Okay, it's right next to me.
Thank God.
I made it so far, and I just got slapped.
One punch!
Okay, we're gonna do this again.
I got an idea.
I'm like, what was that?
There you go.
Wee!
Okay.
They're just tripping off of the...
See, I told you.
I had a plan.
It worked.
Oh my god.
Bro, let him have fun, bro!
There you go.
No fun.
He's like, no fun allowed.
Yeah, it's a lot easier when, you know.
Good girl, Ivy.
It's all easier when I have HP.
I guess you're tunneling into Stranger's Vault below ground.
He got jealous.
He did.
Let people enjoy things.
Exactly.
Gosh, she's so weak.
She has, like, no HP.
There are Ivy's Vines.
And there's the storage facility.
Nice work, Red.
Time to get in there.
Oh, there's a lot of people here.
Open the door.
Okay.
There's the vault.
Looks like a standard three card security protocol.
So standard.
You'd think these people would have learned by now.
Hopefully the keys are down there.
I'm not- what?
I'm just talking to myself.
Like in my head?
I'll need to be quick and stay out of sight.
Break into the vault.
Oh.
Wait, is this self?
Oh no.
Oh.
I can't do anything without the three key cards.
Oh, no.
The only way to get them is to get close enough to the guards and help myself to them.
Wait, this is stealth.
Wait a minute.
This is stealth.
Can I do self-kills?
Oh, I can.
Oh, my God.
I can't even kill him.
Like, what's the point?
Okay.
I need to steal the key cards from the guards.
Wait, can I not kill him?
What's wrong with you, Selena?
Trying to leave without retrieving your precious loot from strange...
Can I actually not kill these guys?
I have to, like...
Oh, no, my weakness.
Can I put them to sleep?
Oh, my God, I can't.
can't oh my god that's so fucked up okay
he has to walk past here right
how does he get over here oh my god i hate this i can't even put him to sleep too just a little guy okay i need him to walk past this vent so i can be like peekaboo the last okay okay i can grab this card
oh god okay i gotta figure out how to get the last one oh this is so annoying okay there's this way how do i get the last one like where does he go all right these guys are terrible guys like yeah they have no peripheral vision like actually no peripheral vision right there How do I get the last one?
Okay.
I'm trying to figure out how to...
How do I crawl to that area?
Oh, the ceiling.
They don't know how to look up, right?
I swear to God, if they start looking up...
Assume he's the last one.
They're gamers.
That's all the keys.
Next stop, the security room.
They did not get drafted to look up, guys.
Alright, we did it.
That was easy.
Wait, these guys are terrible.
Who the fuck hired them?
I might as well not have guards.
Like, what's the point?
I really...
I might as well.
What's the point of having guards?
Is this a drill?
Listen up.
The room is hot.
Spread out and search for intruders.
No prisoners.
I don't like this.
Do you think it's Batman?
I hope not.
We've got special orders.
I don't even need to be a master chief.
These guys are actually like...
I feel like they hired some guy off the street.
Oh, what do I do now?
Oh, okay.
They don't look up, right?
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Oh, now I can kill them.
Oh, okay.
No, I can kill them now.
Wait, I can just chill.
Wait, they actually never look up.
Oh, you guys are right.
Oh, shit!
Okay, it's fine.
Oh, you guys are right.
look up.
Oh, they're covering every angle.
Wait, how the fuck do I do a silent takedown on this?
Wait, they're just like, bro, what the fuck they're camping?
They're not even splitting up, gang.
Bro, they're not even splitting up.
That's it.
Nice.
No, they won't.
If I get rid of all of them.
Check your numbers.
Target spotted.
No, you don't.
Me next.
When they pretend they don't see me.
Oh, shit!
Oh!
That guy was like, no touch!
No touch!
He looked up.
Everyone was pretending, but this guy...
Someone's opening the vault.
Is this a drill?
This guy was not...
It was like, guys, we all see this, right?
He was the only one that didn't want to pretend.
You think it's Batman?
it does laugh we've got special orders for him all right we can take this guy just some Arkham scum trying to get rich this guy he didn't get the member he's the only everyone else was straight but him no
Oh, shit.
No!
Yoink.
No, you don't.
Ha-ha!
Where am I?
But where am I, though?
Yeah, that's right.
Peek-a-boo!
Alright.
That's working, right?
I should have not split up with the gang, bro.
Shouldn't I split up?
I know why I don't stay on on high ground after We have confirmation that target is in the steel mill.
I repeat when he sees this
Last one You're the last one Wait, what if Goodbye
All your friends are gone now.
Open door.
Open sesame.
I did it.
I'm in.
Dr. Cranberry.
Thank you.
Super chat.
Not gonna lie.
If I chance to be choked up by Catwoman's feet, I think I'd be all right.
Thank you.
Oh, shit.
Wait, where the fuck do they come from?
I guess keeps getting better.
That's not what will soon be dead.
What the fuck?
Where the fuck did you guys come from?
Okay Okay, that's not cool, bro.
That's not cool.
I was having a fight here
Okay, I missed the tools not gonna lie.
I do miss it The tools were pretty good I
Oh my god, I'm just getting kicked.
I need to, like, make sure I time the counters correctly, too.
Because there's so many people trying to counter me.
Uh, get out of here.
I can't even do finishers because they're all trying to kick me.
Okay, nice.
That's right, get over here!
Get beat down!
into?
This was a 1v1.
That's right.
You think this was over?
That's acting right.
Batman is down?
Oh god, get my briefcase first.
I got the score of a lifetime.
Oh shit, I'm supposed to get Ivy shit too.
this is awkward.
I forgot to pick up the that.
Oh, shit.
But I'm rich now.
Oh, that's... God.
Whoopsie.
That's... Oh, at least it's... How was I supposed to know I can't pick two?
Well, you tried your best.
Am I supposed to is this like a choice?
What happens if I don't pick up the plant?
Wait, do I have to restart?
Oh my god.
That's bullshit.
Does anything happen?
No, you don't.
Okay.
I can just abandon Batman.
Okay, cool.
She will destroy it.
No, she She just breaks it.
Oh, it doesn't do anything?
Okay.
Oh, she just breaks the plat?
Okay, well, that's fine.
What if it doesn't...
My choices don't matter, I guess.
My choices...
That's fine.
Choices don't matter.
I'm taking...
Oh, wait, there is Batman.
Oh, my God.
Wait, what happened to him?
You can do it.
Just walk right out of here and leave him.
It's easy.
You'll never forgive yourself, Selina.
Save Batman, then get out of here.
What if I just leave?
It's not like he'll die.
You're right.
Wait.
What if I leave?
Go.
Yeah, just leave.
Batman will be fine.
He'll be fine, right?
He has his robins.
He doesn't need me.
Leave Arkham City.
Let's like it go.
Like him.
Yeah, he'll be fine.
He doesn't need me.
Who cares?
Money, money, money.
All right, how much does this affect the story if I say?
Forget Batman.
Wait, the game actually... Oh my god, I can finish the game right now?
I can literally finish the game right now?
Wait, can I?
Oh my god.
Wait, can I actually go back?
Drop suitcases and rescue Batman.
Imagine.
Let's go.
Wait, can I... If I finish this game and it gives me an ending, do I restart the checkpoint or am I fucked?
Alright, GG's, guys.
Screw him.
Yay!
We finished the game!
We got the good ending because we got rich, guys.
Literally said, screw him.
I did it!
Yay!
And we speedrun.
Batman died!
I would say that's a good ending.
It's okay.
One of the robins will just take over.
We don't need no man.
Oh shit, everyone.
Well, it's Catwoman's good ending.
Oh.
Where the fuck is Superman?
The game was like, okay, let's do this again, Doki.
Let's see if Superman has his own problems.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I was like, what the fuck?
Is Superman just letting Gotham City just go, like, just go out?
Anarchy like who I I assume Gotham City is it's not its own state, you know I assume Gotham City is also part of the United States and because it's still part of the United States of America You know the other superheroes would come in and help them out.
It's easy You'll never forgive yourself.
Not my city Out of his jurisdiction of fucking having the justice league if the league ain't gonna help since when did you grow a conscience
yes i'll have to help batman i'm coming to save you i guess ain't no league here it's like the league is here to help everyone but batman all right where is batman in the steel mill all right
It's like...
See what I give up for you, Batman.
Everything but Gotham City.
It's not their jurisdiction.
Well, what do we have here?
Gotham City pays similar space taxes?
If not, Bruce Wayne has funded like 50% of America.
You're right.
I think I chipped a nail back there.
You stick with the green.
handle the wisecracks.
She just needs someone to pick up, like, some rubble?
10 is now, right?
If you're planning on stopping it, you need to hurry.
Yeah, if Flash gets in trouble, every Justice League member comes to save him.
That's it!
They lost Gotham City because he couldn't get out of a pile of rocks?
See, like, totally look at that.
Like, um, we can't even check if it's a mirror or not.
Really?
You're right.
Bruce Wayne has, like, 90% tax cut.
You're so right.
Strange is launching missile strikes on Arkham City from Wonder Tower.
You shut this place down.
Joker's taken Talia.
Yeah, the Tibetan monks did not teach him how to get out of rocks.
I need your help to stop the attack.
He'll kill Talia.
You need to think this through.
Batman can't let all these people die.
My tracker is not activating.
Wayne Tech satellites to boost the signal I can't do that but how much more do I have from the game you need to decide if one life is worth sacrificing to save a thousand oh the trolley problem I'm sorry but deep down Oracle do not lose yeah but how much is two three fours like the towers locked down two hours no way in without the codes one of the choppers will be carrying the I'm debating if I want to I'm debating if I want to finish it now or finish it later two to three hours okay we're okay I'm gonna cash in on the bane quest real quick first
I'm gonna cash in on the bane quest
all right give me the bane cash out first All right, we don't care about the scan to locate mastery.
Okay, we don't care about that yet.
I'll cash in on the Bane shit first.
Oh, there's the missiles.
I mean, they're killing the criminals, which is more than what I did.
How the fuck did I get inside again?
I don't remember.
Oh, wait, that's just the water.
Oh, there it is.
Alright.
I got the Titan.
Then?
Oh, there you are.
I was like, where did you go?
I destroyed the containers, Bing.
Good.
On the ground, prisoner.
Now.
Oh, shit.
Help me, Papa.
We must not have...
Alright, you could literally just crush them.
Like, you don't...
What the fuck?
Okay, that's a lot.
Never mind.
That's a lot.
Okay, can you Grab one of them, at least, bro.
Bro, come on, bro.
Okay, there we go.
That's what I like to see.
That's what I like to see, bro.
I would like it if you don't try and get the same people I'm getting, you know?
Bam, bam, bam, bam.
Do it.
Boom.
Wait, I got this combo, so...
Okay, that was me.
You accidentally hit me.
Okay, bro, dude.
Sorry.
Yeah, yeah, no shit.
Friendly fire.
As I was saying, I've destroyed mine.
I take it you've done the same.
Okay, back to your actual conversation.
powerful to be used against me what i needed it all for myself now do me a favor wait no he relapsed no bain he relapsed i knew i couldn't trust you bain so i used you instead what what simple you rounded up the remaining titan that's right watch me destroy it stop that's right got it bro we this is an intervention bro god this is an intervention bang you know this is a problem we're all concerned about you watch this that's right your supplies god we're here to help you bane what happened we're helping you I warned you,
Bane.
Free me.
No.
You'll get out.
Eventually.
I'm too busy to keep biting you.
Yeah, you gotta, like, call Alfred to pencil yourself in.
You can't do this to me.
Don't worry.
We'll sign you up.
We'll sign you up on Titan Anonymous.
We're gonna get you to help you, Nene, Bane.
Alright, let's see.
What do we want to...
What do we want to upgrade?
Line launcher, tight rope, Sonic.
What's this?
I feel like I don't really need that hacking that much.
Free flow focus.
We're achieving.
We'll enter free flow.
Oh, wait, that's cool.
I want to try that.
He's in his little timeout corner.
Oh, I could have given her armor.
Whoops.
I don't know.
I feel like I don't use Catwoman enough to justify giving her my upgrades.
Like, does she not have her own?
Does she like share my upgrades chat?
Like, does she even share it?
No?
Oh, okay, so I just have to play her.
Like, like my level ups.
If I get the XP, does she share my level ups for XP?
Oh, it's auto rain.
Oh, she shares XP.
Okay, so if I already use it so she can use it when I'm I'm playing here.
I get it.
All right.
We're gonna comment here because I want to I don't think I can play I don't know if I can play two more hours today Just because like tomorrow I do have a stream tomorrow and it's sponsor related I don't know if I can announce it yet, but it will be on YouTube the sponsor So that's why I don't want to overdo it.
Maybe I want to do a rival stream later.
Who knows?
Oh, I should scan I might as well scan it right now out like since he's here he's easier already so i'm better as well oh he doesn't have the master control all right i guess bye i mean well now we know that helicopter didn't have it but yeah that's fun though it's fun playing i really i really i've been really um enjoying batman so far um it's really i feel like the arkham series they did they did so many callbacks to a of like the law like history around batman i feel like if damian was around that time they would have included damian as well um i wonder if jason shows up or any of the other uh robins show up but it's been really fun so far and i'm enjoying myself uh yeah i'm gonna call it here everybody i hope you guys had a fun time watching as always um yeah it's very it's sad that you know the arkham series um got worse as it went on.
It's fucked up that the Arkham series was not about Batman later on.
Like, I think that's fucked up.
And then they killed him off, too.
They killed off Batman in his own fucking series, which I will say is very messed up to do.
And then they're like, don't worry, guys.
We're bringing the Arkham series back.
But you can only play it in VR.
Like, Yippee
Um Um but yeah Tomorrow we do have another We have a sponsor stream Usually I don't stream on Sunday But like I said We do have a sponsor And also I haven't started my street fighter training yet But I feel like I should I should start today Just because I feel really bad Because like I saw my teammates Have already started practicing But already started practicing For the street fighter tournament next week So So I gotta practice that starting today because I have yet to touch Tree Fighter.
But anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture checked, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you step for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
Also, I hope you guys enjoyed yesterday's Halloween stream.
It was a great time hanging out with all you guys yesterday.
I forgot to say, like, happy Halloween yesterday.
So I want to say, happy belated Halloween.
anyway guys i'll see you guys next time everyone bye guys bye